[Laughter]
thank you
hey everybody it's Friday night yep
Friday before Halloween yeah very very
excited
although we're not doing anything
tonight we all we are going to uh
Halloween party tomorrow night what I
forgot to bring my damn power cable hold
on one sec man you had like half an hour
man I was getting ready to get myself a
damn injection and everything when all
this [ __ ]
you do know how clocks work right
[Laughter]
man
I don't know I don't get it I don't get
it
hey you John Smith haven't seen you
around here in a while
uh Daniel rolling's telling dad jokes
already
yeah it's just you know
haven't even really gotten them
gotten the swing of the night yet but
yeah
like I said there's actually
there's a Halloween party tonight which
is Memento Mori but I don't think I
think we're gonna go to the one tomorrow
night
uh because then I'll have more time to
like do my costume because that's gonna
take a while because it's complicated
John Smith said I've been away a month
and Tom's growing a beard yeah yeah
it's really it's been that long
since you've been gone yeah I guess so
who is it John Smith okay
Pat Hatfield says howdy John Smith house
Pocahontas
I like that I like that you might want
to like turn the fan on yeah man look
people I'm kind of behind schedule
because hold on these kids got cats
walking around
all right
yeah I don't I don't know I'm off the
trend
took my last injection of that [ __ ]
three days ago
so
they're starting to come out of that out
of my system
at least high levels of it
I'm never gonna do that [ __ ] again
the [ __ ] Trend wasn't worth it yeah
well it gave results but I couldn't
used a much more pleasant compound would
have taken a little bit longer and cost
a little bit more money but that
emotional roller coaster there man
um
welcome to being a woman all the time
it's like being a woman
you don't want to be a woman well
you're right I don't no no I'm just no
you don't want to be a woman not really
you're [ __ ]
your test levels will be spiked through
the roof your [ __ ] estrogen levels
are way down nothing and then you're
[ __ ] got a [ __ ] ton of progesterone
going on in there and
straight men don't have [ __ ] that
that much progesterone
that's like
women and some gay guys have a [ __ ] ton
of progesterone and it just makes you
[ __ ] think you're Morrissey and
[ __ ] well I never thought I was more
you get like you would get I would get
like
uh oh super confident almost bulletproof
at certain times but then on the other
hand also like insecure thinking people
were talking about you yeah
um a bunch of opposites happening at the
same time you're just on this total
[ __ ] and you know it's your
imagination you know it's the it's those
hormones
um but
so it's not as strong as say like LSD
where you have hallucinations but you
know you're having these feelings and
you know that they're not grounded in
anything it's just
hormones are mind altering mood altering
big time
I've had that kind of [ __ ] like every
day as long as I can remember that's why
you are that way I mean like I like this
well every day I know
how many times like every single night
this happens almost every single night I
wake up in the middle of the night
usually because I have to pee and then
like several times and then like I'll
wake up and I'll come back to bed and
then I'll start like having anxiety and
usually it's not like anxiety because
usually what it is it's not so much
because I kind of feel like you went
more back into like [ __ ] that happened
in the past yeah like feeling about
stuff my stuff is like more like the
future like um like oh man like I have
to do all this and that and what if that
doesn't work out and all this other kind
of stuff and then like I'll lay there
for like two and three hours and then
I'm like why the [ __ ] am I doing this to
myself it's like why am I worrying it's
like stuff will work out but it but yet
I tell myself that every time but it
never works like it never goes away so
it's like every single night like or
every in the middle of the night I
always wake up and I always do that and
then I always have to talk myself down
it happens every single time and I'm
it's really it's sucky it's sucky and
it's like and I can't like get out of it
you know what I mean Dave's here
hey yo you two hey what's up Dave
yeah they say I'm a trend of science man
that's right eating them damn Trend
baloney sandwiches Trend bologna
sandwich yeah Jeff hard said at least
women get to have multiple orgasms LOL
yeah it has not much of a trade-off to
be honest with you
Trend did weird things from a [ __ ]
sex drive I was [ __ ] constantly ready
to get them it was making her bad
and uh Tran and Viagra is a dangerous
combination
yeah you can just go forever and ever
and never come and she's like come on
let's get this over with I'm like no man
no what are you talking about [ __ ]
the wood's great man the wood's great
I'm having a great time I like it's been
like two hours though yeah I'm falling
asleep yeah just fall asleep you know
I'm trying to watch the rest of the gear
but no Toro series
no it's just uh it's uncontrollable it's
unreasonable he's not he's unreasonable
it's unreasonable and then like you'll
get some weird [ __ ] that happened where
you uh no sex drive at all where you're
just like you don't give a [ __ ] you know
probably couldn't you probably couldn't
even Rock up if you had [ __ ] Viagra
each it's like this constant three-day
cycle over and over again and then you
start drifting down
the last few days I started going into
what's called God mode
where which like I said you don't need
that yeah I went into god mode that was
about because that's kind of like your
natural state oh no it's worse
when God mode started all of a sudden I
just got real flat and even and calm and
cool and collected felt real good that
day then the day after that I felt like
a
Superior like I was a demigod you know
like I was a slightly different version
of mankind and everybody else
[Laughter]
bug you know what I mean and then day
three
I was like no I'm better than other
people
yeah
you don't need that yeah [ __ ] it's
the feeling of [ __ ] just Supremacy
narcissism this is why you should start
to do cocaine this is why you shouldn't
right because you already have those
Tendencies you know no offense but you
already have extreme narcissism yeah but
I wasn't as far as I could tell
expressing it I was just feeling it
okay well that's good because if you
just said something like that to me yeah
smacked you in the mouth no
no no well a lot of the [ __ ] that I went
through I wasn't expressing it
so I'd [ __ ] I'd call I'd call sof the
contact Soph and tell her what I was
feeling and then she's well you can tell
Jenny that because I had to check it out
with her first
you know I had to check it out that's
like that's so weird it's funny
that's so weird because I thought you I
thought you
I was getting paranoid
I thought you were breaking up with me
was one of the things that I thought for
a while
yeah you told me that yeah I thought
that I I thought that you were mad at me
a lot of times uh which no you weren't
I thought you you you have these
feelings that are not that aren't
supported by anything it's just uh
so I was afraid I'd get in trouble for
the way that I felt
so I'd have to check it because see I
told Soph this is what I'm taking and
she watched the videos on what what it
was I was saying you know she's like oh
yeah that shit's probably gonna [ __ ] you
up it's just you know but are you gonna
talk me through it she's like I'm gonna
talk you through it I'm gonna talk this
she taught me through it well that's
good yeah
you got to work
here's the thing it was like
a lot of the times I had to kind of like
uh
go in the man cave and kind of [ __ ]
sequester myself that was like or stay
away from other people
because
I was afraid I might say things or do
something that was [ __ ] unacceptable
you get very insecure on it yeah you get
really insecure on it
I mean I've read horror stories where
dudes have just looked at their wives
and go God damn you're [ __ ] ugly you
know they say [ __ ] like that to them or
they do weird [ __ ]
especially when they start hitting that
damn god mode everybody looks like a bug
you know and they're like you're so
stupid well you know what though I kind
of feel like I mean I've known you for
such a long time and I know that you're
on that stuff like if you came up with
like with some [ __ ] like that and it's
been like yeah you're right bye and then
gone back in my room
one dude once one dude said he was at
dinner with his wife and his
mother-in-law
and [ __ ] he didn't know what he did
or said but he the Mother-in-law was uh
he talked the Mother-in-law into tears
and [ __ ] and they wouldn't repeat what
it was he said he didn't remember what
he said yikes yeah he said something to
her
um
and then another guy said he said
something crazy to um his best friend's
wife and they wouldn't speak to him
anymore wouldn't repeat what he said
he sets up though must have been
something bad I'm bad something bad
about her yeah
see that's what you get from running
your damn mouth yeah so I was kind of
like saying well if I'm gonna go on this
[ __ ] I'm gonna have to [ __ ] keep my
[ __ ] wired tight and try to lay low for
that time you know because there's no
telling what I might say or do or but
then once it starts kicking in you're
like oh no this isn't a big deal
it's not really a big deal but then like
your
you think you're doing okay but you may
not be doing okay you're not sure
just like if you're on LSD you know
you got to keep checking it like am I
[ __ ] enough am I saying right now
yeah
yeah
but um
it's over with now and I don't I changed
it it it did do some physical changes to
me
but I could have done that with another
compound that was
a lot more pleasant to take this would
have taken longer
that's the way to go thank you Senor
sticks are you going to be Gomez and
Morticia or Herman and Lily now we've
never done that actually I think the
only time that we ever did
well I don't even think we did that well
we didn't do it on purpose but like a
long time ago where you were like you
look kind of like Jack the Ripper and I
was like Jack the Ripper victim like
with intestines hanging out that was a
long time ago that was a long time ago
I'm going I'm going as Bane the wrestler
Bay
yeah did you see a comic book version of
a right not the movie version of Bane I
got I got the I got the damn Luchador
mask and everything
most of the costume I don't have the
injector kit I'd have to build that and
I don't think I'll have a bother really
well I was gonna say you don't have that
long to do it if you're planning to do
it
and I hadn't even seen one of those for
sale I think every time I've seen one it
looks like a custom job somebody's made
Danny Rowling said Jenny you're gonna
going as the fish lady from Dagon for
Hollywood one of these days I'm gonna do
it but like I said if I do that costume
I gotta do it
I gotta do it right I gotta get a
wheelchair I gotta get some tentacles I
gotta get like make the crown and all
that kind of stuff and I didn't have
time to do it this year
um looks like Jenny is going to be
Wednesday now because I this is just
kind of like well I wear this dress
anyway
just because I like it but I just I was
wearing this today because I was
recording a video about The Addams
Family Halloween special which is going
up tomorrow so that's why so I thought
it would be funny if I wore the
Wednesday dress that's all
[Laughter]
but actually I'm not um
I haven't told anybody like you know
what I'm gonna be for homie but I'm I
gotta I gotta um
I got a few things I got to do tomorrow
I tried to get like ahead on all my
videos and everything like that so I had
time tomorrow to like sort my [ __ ] out
because
I have it in my head like how it's gonna
go but I want to have like extra time
before we go to the party in case I [ __ ]
something up you know what I mean yeah
so
but I've been watching I've been
watching like tutorials and I've been
like doing all that kind of stuff so you
know
actually Jenny will be green but it's
not
she's not it's not it's not uh poison
ivy no no it's not the arcade I'm not
gonna tell him anything
um it's not gonna it's not it's not even
related to comic books at all yeah
yeah I'm not like I'm not a big comic
book person to be honest with me
I'm just wearing that costume because I
already have it okay see because I think
you were I think he wore it last year
and only wore it once yeah yeah you wore
it last year I think well yeah because I
think we went to the Halloween party at
mannequins last year because I think I
did I was Bride of Frankenstein right
because I remember buying that white
buying that white dress
and doing and you doing the video with
like the big boobs because I had the
white bra okay
so yeah I remember that so I think I did
I did Wednesday like for one of the
shows but then I think I did write a
Frankenstein
and then I think the year before that I
did
uh Amy from Fright Night like the
vampire version
that was a couple years ago I think that
was still at the old house I'm pretty
sure
John Smith said LSD can make you a
little wacky it's fair to say I saw the
movie Noah on LSD
I wouldn't recommend that
that's a good movie and it was the most
terrifying movie of all time yeah it was
a good mood
I I honestly I would not um I would not
advise watching any Darren aronowsky
movies on LSD or David Lynch movies or
uh the guy that made Mandy that the
great the Greek guy yeah so uh any of
that
I I don't think that'd be such a good
idea Zach says Hey Y'all what's up I'm
broke and my vape died oh
man I've forgotten all about
Vapes
remember how like when we first stopped
smoking
like all those all those years ago
and you got like super super into the
whole Vape thing yeah they like got me
to stop smoking it yeah but like you we
I don't even remember how much money you
spent like on all the rigs yeah like
mixing your own juice and all that other
kind of stuff
all that other kind of stuff I just
worked it did yeah it's like I'm just
saying it's funny to like think of now
how much money we spent on it and let's
go have all it yeah it's just that uh
I don't don't you know me got to where I
was like ah you know I'd forget to carry
it with me
you know they're like well I guess I
don't have to vape then vaping went away
yeah that's what happened with me too
like I noticed that you know I would
take it with me and like sometimes I had
it next to me like in my office and I
was just like not
and I just wasn't doing it
like you know and I realized I was like
oh well okay I guess I don't really need
to do that and then like when I tried to
do it again later it just like made me
cough
foreign
LSD plus mushrooms while watching a
Cronenberg movie or Star Trek the motion
picture yeah
uh Mercer Horton said LSD lasts too long
if you have a bad trip you have a long
ride to to wait
I guess so yeah never had a bad trip
I guess well I mean some people do
though
it does I would actually surprised by
how long it took to take effect
I think that was I don't know what
surprised me yeah it was like 45 minutes
to an hour because it's fun I guess
because they always show like in movies
like somebody takes it and then like
immediately they're like woo and I'm
like yeah that's not how that works like
it waited it takes like a really long
time and honestly like at least in my
experience it just came on like really
subtly you know what I mean like it
wasn't like immediately like oh wow it
was just kind of like you just noticed
little things you know what I mean
it was that
um yeah John Smith said that trip lasted
18 hours far too long Jesus Christ
yeah I don't like that one time
I don't know it didn't seem to last that
long
how long did how long did that last
probably about 12 hours I guess maybe
not even that long
I can't remember like it was still like
night time because I think we took it in
the afternoon
senior six has never seen a racer head I
kind Eraserhead is what I mean if you're
into like films or anything you probably
should see it it's
it's something
it's something
it's not my favorite David Lynch movie
but I mean that would probably be
Mulholland Drive
but you know what I mean
Kevin Smith says happy spooky season Tom
and Jen uh thank you very much yeah I'm
very excited about it got a whole bunch
of pumpkins
wait did we buy any candy yet
we did there's some candy down there oh
okay she was expensive
yeah yeah I didn't know if you got candy
last time you were at the store yeah
because I was like well [ __ ] maybe I
should go get that
what happened Polk
just like before the show
I was sitting here in my at my desk over
there and I heard her crashing around
like and then I heard her yelling like
from the other room like and I'm like
what the [ __ ] so I ran in there and she
was out in the little living room
on the second floor chasing a lizard
I don't know how the [ __ ] lizard got
in here
but she was chasing it around so I
caught it let it out Tom caught it let
it out shoot it's weird because she
doesn't
um
she doesn't hurt him just tries to hold
him like not you know I mean obviously
like if she plays with him long enough
she does but she doesn't seem to mean
she doesn't want to hurt them it seems
like she just kind of wants to play with
them yeah and like sometimes they get
hurt like in the course of that but
she's not like well because I had a cat
a long time ago that would play with the
lizards but then would like bite their
heads off you know what I mean like she
would eat them partially Pookie doesn't
do that she just seems like she likes to
chase him and kind of like play with him
a little bit but she's not like trying
to hurt him
and let's see
Senor sticks will you be scaring the
teenagers and the children in costume uh
perhaps
we'll see how it comes out we didn't
have that many trick-or-treaters last
year we didn't I mean I mean we might
have more this year just because I don't
know though it's a Monday night
so I don't know if it's gonna be yeah I
don't really remember us having that
many
last year because we were in this house
last year right yeah that's right yep
because we had been here for like a
month or something
and
oh yeah I don't really remember
um Senor sticks if one pranks you with
toilet paper hey free toilet paper
um Zach says my boyfriend's birthday is
tomorrow actually and I wanted to get
him something but you know broke
sometimes late birthday presents are the
best because they're unexpected or you
could just make something
you know what I mean yeah
okay so let's open lines we're gonna be
here drinking and uh ushering you guys
into the weekend this is uh yeah your
work day is probably over or getting
near to be over
and uh we're gonna just sit here and
drink and we'll talk about stuff if you
guys want to uh you know have any good
topics or you want to ask any questions
we you can just go ahead and drop them
in the comments section and we can uh go
ahead and start uh talking about
talking about what you guys want to talk
about
in the meantime Jenny Jen and I are just
going to sit here if we can talk to
Pookie
and uh watch our ice melt is that ice is
melting the [ __ ] out of itself it is why
is it so hot in here it's not that hot
outside it's not hot is it for some
reason
the ice the ice that comes out of the
ice makers never seems to be enough to
really keep both of the glasses cold
and uh
[ __ ] ice melts quickly let me go see
how much is in here now that's the thing
even when I get up in the morning like
when it's kind of cool still like I'll
put a bunch of ice and then I'll put
water in there in the morning like you
know I sit here and like do work for for
20 minutes and I look over and all the
[ __ ] ice is melted
and it's not you know it's not hot in
here it's just
senior stick says drinking and pumpkin
carving
yeah those are two I haven't even done
the jack-o-lane I haven't done any
jack-o-lanterns this year I kind of like
Tom went to the pumpkin patch the other
day and like bought a bunch of pumpkins
but I don't know if I'm gonna have time
to carve them though a whole bunch of
ice waiting there oh okay well that's
good did you bring me some yeah oh okay
I thought you like brought some in a
thingy
but
I kind of figured probably well just
cook the pumpkins and make some stuff
out of them like soup and bread and
everything like that
because that's the thing like the house
we live in now you can't really
um you can't really see any of the
windows from the street you know what I
mean and I don't and we're gonna use the
pumpkins like for food so I don't want
to put them outside because like bubs
bugs will crawl all over them so when we
lived at the old house like we had a
window in the front that you could see
from the road and that um you know
because the driveway wasn't that long so
you could put the pumpkins like inside
like in the window and people could
still see them but this house
mostly all you can see from the road one
we have like a super super long driveway
like this ridiculously long driveway and
then like all you can see mostly is the
garage and then you can kind of see the
front door and then there's like
trees and bushes and stuff and there's
like a window but you can't really see
it honestly you can see the upstairs
Windows more than
the downstairs I was thinking that the
other day I was like maybe we should put
the Christmas tree on the second floor
like you could probably see it better
because if you put it in the front
window you can't see [ __ ] you can't see
it
um let's see did you see Rob Zombie's
monsters
um
I didn't really feel any desire to I
mean I know we just we put up the video
earlier today we were talking about
House of a Thousand Corpses and I
actually remember and I liked that a lot
more than I remembered because I'd seen
it in the theater like a long time ago
and then we watched it again and I was
like oh yeah that was a lot better than
I remembered and I like The Devil's
Rejects and all that kind of stuff but I
don't know I saw a trailer and I saw
James from Cinemassacre like talking
about the Monsters movie and I was like
um that really looks like
um an hour and a half that I'll wish
that I had back so I was like maybe I
shouldn't the thing about like
the thing that I thought was so funny
about the um the cinemascar guys review
was that you could tell that he very
very clearly wanted to like it but that
he probably didn't really like it but he
was like trying to be charitable you
know what I mean which I kind of feel
like I do that too a little bit but
because I usually try to find positives
in anything I don't let I don't like I
don't like to be like one of those
people that just like shits on
everything
but you know sometimes it just you know
some people I saw some people really
liked it which you know that's fair but
I don't know it just doesn't look like
anything that I would want to watch
it's just I don't know it just it didn't
look funny it looked cool like the
visuals looked cool but it didn't look
like it was funny you can read what
David said right there uh so going to
dinner with my family and then going to
mannequins tonight for that hillbilly
theme I actually found a Halloween
costume that fits my big ass but I'm
wearing that tomorrow yeah we're
probably gonna come to uh mannequins
tomorrow night tomorrow yeah
um because like I said I'll probably
need like all day to do my [ __ ]
costume because I don't know how it's
gonna work out yeah how tall are you
David
he's [ __ ] big he's got to be [ __ ]
six foot [ __ ] four six foot five huh
if you guys don't know [ __ ] Dave
you've never met a man he's a [ __ ]
mountain of a man
he's like yeah now when I say sometimes
you know like well you know like
sometimes we've talked about like
hand-to-hand combat and I said you have
to just understand something [ __ ]
size and mass matters a lot in it in a
fight okay if a dude could pick you up
you're probably not going to be able to
[ __ ] beat his ass in the same way
that that's the reason why children
cannot beat up adults because you can
just throw them around again I would
like to go up against [ __ ] I wouldn't
be like to go up against it man look I
think he's about [ __ ] six four maybe
yeah he's he's a heavyweight guy
but
that boy and hurt you he's gonna end up
on the ground all he's got to do is
[ __ ] just grab you and fall and then
you he'll take you down with him and he
just roll over on you and [ __ ] get
you into a [ __ ] Stranglehold and
that's it because most fights end up on
the ground anyway
that's true but [ __ ] he's a good
example of [ __ ] in a fight bigger is
better really
yeah all that [ __ ] you see on the
[ __ ] Frank Frazetta [ __ ] posters
of [ __ ] Conan flying through the air
where the [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
sword fighting a giant it's like [ __ ]
four times his size and he's winning he
wouldn't go down that way
how hilarious Larry to be a Frank
Frazetta just for shits and giggles had
painted yeah like a giant herb like an
ogre or something he was just holding
coding up by the head yeah yeah yeah
now I kind of want to see yeah
okay six spots are under attack can you
guys kill off the sex box it's the same
one it's the same one from before yeah
we have a couple we have a couple uh
and we have a couple wrenches in here a
couple wrenches yeah
[Laughter]
but um Senor 6 said Jenny be a better
Lily monster than Sherry Moon thank you
I probably would be out of imagine
um yeah the funny thing Dave he's going
to mannequins and that's where we're
going tomorrow night the theme they're
doing tonight they're doing like a Rob
Zombie Hellbilly theme it's actually
called Halloween because I did the
poster
um tomorrow night is the one that we're
going to is horrorween which you're
supposed to like dress as a villain from
like you know villains from horror
movies that's kind of like I'm sure
everyone's just gonna wear whatever
because they do they do themes like
every weekend because like I said I do
like mostly the posters for them not
like every weekend but they try to do
like themes for a lot of weekends but
you know that you'll always have like a
handful of people
that do the theme
depending on what it is
um and then people that just kind of
like wander in and be like wow why is
everybody like wearing weird [ __ ] you
know what I mean it's that kind of stuff
but
I don't I don't know how it's gonna turn
out tonight with the with the hillbilly
theme
that's a good idea though it's gonna be
all right yeah they always have they
always have blowouts over there they do
yeah that place is always [ __ ] packed
man it's packed and it's always [ __ ]
having a blowout yeah I'm proud of what
he did
I didn't believe in it at first
it was too small but when he brought
when he got the place next to it and
busted out the walls he was working with
something I knew he was working yeah it
was very small to start with but yeah he
bought the next door please too and like
so he doubled the size right and he's
really been like working a lot on it you
know
like and it seemed it's like every time
we go it's [ __ ] mobbed in there yeah
it's packed I don't know how much money
he makes at that place but it's got to
be a lot a lot
he's even he's even got all the night
he's even got all the patio out back and
you look at his traffic if you look at
his traffic he's he's beating the Eye
bar
old Eye bar yeah old Eye bar downtown he
some nights probably yeah yeah I mean
eyebar was much bigger yeah that's one
thing but it was more expensive
that's true the rent that eyeball was
[ __ ] amazing well yeah because it was
like a corner right downtown yeah so no
he's beating ibar
and I just went down to downtown Sanford
yesterday because I'm going to be uh
doing graphic design for another bar
that's opening down there like that's
not that far from mannequins actually I
was I always forget I don't know why I
don't
go hang out in downtown Sanford more I
guess because it's like a half hour
drive and it's like I don't really have
time to go all the way down there but
every time I go down there I'm like man
there's so much cool [ __ ] down here
there's like a cool like old like used
bookstore there's like you know all kind
of like little cafes and coffee shops
and like cool little boutiques and [ __ ]
like that I'm like little antique shops
it's like I don't know why I don't go
there more often it's not big it's only
like a few blocks but
thank you Jeffy art tomorrow my friends
are having a pumpkin painting party
that's cool spent fifty dollars at Total
Wine on ingredients for pumpkin pie
cocktail experiment ooh tell us how that
turns out that sounds yummy I got about
six Pumpkins Sitting downstairs that's
what I said he went to the pumpkin pie
and like I don't yeah are you gonna make
like pies and bread and stuff yeah
and soup yeah and Curry oh Pumpkin Curry
let's make all this to make all that
there's gonna be I'm gonna oh my God
yeah I'm gonna have to like ride my bike
so much more like to keep from Gaining a
million pounds well it keeps
it keeps for a long time you know we'll
have to use those right away
you know and uh I can make the uh
I can make slurry and freeze it because
I had that freezer out back
yeah
and last time we got we just got two
medium to large sized pumpkins and man
that made a [ __ ] ton of stuff yeah so
now we've got six of them yeah some of
them are pie pumpkins and some of and
the other ones are like bread pumpkins
yeah
because man I could eat pumpkin stuff
yeah and then I got butternut squash
this is my favorite time of year so like
for food I mean for other things too
like because it's Halloween and the
holidays and stuff and I love that kind
of [ __ ] and it's full of its cooler
weather and everything but the food man
yeah all locally sourced I got them from
a farm over there
little pumpkin patch yeah it's a pumpkin
patch it's a pumpkin patch and uh they
got squash in there they had tomatoes
and onions and I got tomatoes and onions
out of there too they're real good
you've been eating
is that did you put that in the pasta or
was that something else uh no no some
canned stuff oh [ __ ] pasta was
[ __ ] terrible but I liked it you
liked it I didn't like that sauce that
was I liked that sauce because it was
mild that was Prego that I spiced up
yeah I can't stand Prego
I was just I just used it to get rid of
it
because that's not as good as my sauce
well nothing's as good as your sauce no
I kind of feel like when I live by
myself like on the rare occasions that I
bought pasta sauce yeah I don't think I
ever got prego I think I would usually
get I guess you look at Ragu or I got
new or Newman's Own yeah regulars matter
I kind of like I I tend to like a
sweeter sauce yeah yeah you know what I
mean I don't like like if it gets like I
said if it gets too sour like it starts
giving me heartburn or like prego's
[ __ ] tart
I didn't notice that though I thought it
was like kind of mild although like
because I added salt yeah I added
[ __ ] sugar to it oh okay totally
re-spiced it oh okay well that's why
that's why it was better then yeah I put
because I was like oh this is nice and
mild and had like some nice chunks set
to me because I like I like a chunky
well the chunks of tomatoes yeah I like
a canned tomatoes that I have oh okay I
added those two I like a chunky sauce
yeah but it but the base was just Prego
out of the dam out of the jar and I had
to use it yeah I just used I had about
that much but see that's what they
always tell you to do man that's just
kind of like didn't they used to have
that show on Food Network that was
called
um what was it called like partially
handmade or partially homemade or
something like that
um where they would like they would buy
like yeah like Jarred tomato like Jarred
pasta sauce or like a boxed cake mix or
something like that but they'd show you
like how to doctor it up so it was like
a lot better you know what I mean yeah
um slasher Fred said speaking of
pumpkins one of my favorite Halloween
specials is It's the Great Pumpkin
Charlie Brown yeah that's still like one
of the best ones to be honest with you
they've made new ones and like I said I
I'm putting up a video tomorrow over at
my scare Salon Channel I found the
um Adams Family Halloween special from
1977 and I was like holy [ __ ] it's free
so I said I'm gonna do a whole video
about this [ __ ] because I saw it when I
was five years old when it came out like
on NBC and I hadn't seen it since then
so I wanted to like uh re-watch it
and it was um
you'll see you'll see I talked about it
on there
uh let's see and justice for me said a
slight deviation for pumpkins did you
ever hit Halloween Horror Nights I went
oh a long time ago a long time ago and
it was fun it was really fun but I kind
of feel like it's probably like a lot
better now because I think they've
really kind of upped their game since
then I don't even remember the last time
lived but I've been like a long time ago
but I don't think you've probably never
been though no like I said but it's been
going on forever I remember yeah yeah
it's always expensive it is and it's not
really my thing I really don't care
I would like to go but I can't afford it
yeah I really don't care I can't afford
it but like I said I did have a good
time going to the Disney thing but
that's not exactly the same because it's
not supposed to be like scary because
that's like more targeted toward I mean
they don't want to scare the [ __ ] out of
like little kids and stuff whereas
Halloween Horror Nights is very very
adult uh you know they they sell booze
everywhere and everybody's zombies are
coming out and grabbing you and [ __ ]
like Orlando [ __ ] Orlando gets there
Orlando area gets everything all right
they get Halloween Horror Nights they
get [ __ ] I think they even get some
of the toy fairs and [ __ ] that happened
and just uh [ __ ] Spooky Empire Spooky
Empire they have everything horror
convention it's just the the thing is is
uh they're expensive and
I'm just not that interested in them you
know like I said I would like to go but
kind of a pain I've been once before
yeah and the thing about it is that I
had a good time like when I went but
it's a lot of money and they're always
really crowded because they always like
sell out you know what I mean well
that's the thing when I went to the
Disney one it wasn't too bad but all the
Disney
um Halloween nights that they did like
all of them sold out so it was like way
more crowded than I was expecting yeah
like especially like to go to the
Haunted Mansion and stuff it was like a
four [ __ ] 45 minute wait all right
David came back he says he's actually
six foot he's just a pinch over 400
pounds down from 500. John said he's a
mountain
and some people might say well man those
specs don't sound all that [ __ ]
healthy well look that does Health
doesn't matter too much in a fight he's
a [ __ ] big dude 400 pound guy six
foot tall you're not gonna be able to do
a whole lot of damage to him if he gets
a hold of you
[ __ ] it you wouldn't want to [ __ ]
fight [ __ ] Dave
nah you wouldn't work and he's a
friendly guy
but no you wouldn't want to fight that
dude yeah it was awesome yeah
for goth Warrior
they basically you're dealing with
Kingpin
I'm [ __ ] from from [ __ ]
Daredevil you're dealing with Kingpin
uh is Art the clown a new horror icon I
guess so I think terrifyer too has like
cemented that
you know because I had forgotten because
not only was he in All Hallows Eve I
forgot they made an All Hallows Eve too
which I don't think I've I've seen it
but I haven't reviewed it and then they
made terrifier which is great and then
terrifier too which everybody's talking
about because it's like oh it's the
bloodiest horror movie ever so I'm like
well now I'm gonna have to see it
because now everybody's talking about oh
my God people are throwing up and
fainting I'm like I don't believe that
but it's like now I still kind of want
to see it so I guess that worked
um John Smith said an odd Halloween
movie I like the documentary hellhouse
from 2001 about those messed up
Christian Halloween scarem to Jesus
houses I think I saw that like a long
time ago I need to really watch that
because yeah that's a whole weird
and I think I've talked about this book
before but this I have this book that
came out like several years ago that's
called Rapture Ready and it's all about
um like Christian entertainment like I
said because we've talked about it
before like um you know that park that's
here what the [ __ ] is the name of it
holy land experience or whatever and I
think he did um a chapter in there where
he was talking about the hell houses
which are like haunted houses like the
Jaycees haunted houses and stuff but
they're always kind of like Christian
themed so it's always like you'll go to
hell if you get an abortion and you'll
go to the league they're trying to scare
people that way so it's that kind of
[ __ ]
uh and yeah there was a documentary
about it I think I saw it but I'm gonna
have to like re-watch it uh And Justice
For Me says never been myself talking
about uh Halloween Horror Nights but
their Exorcist alien and American
werewolf Productions look pretty damn
good yeah I mean they spend a lot of
money on those houses and you know it's
Universal so they have all the [ __ ] they
have all the money they have all the
licensing so I mean and even the one
that I went to several years ago I can't
remember what the themes
I think they had an exorcist one when I
was there
and I can't remember what the other
themes were though because I can't
remember what year it was so I don't
remember what was big that year because
they usually do something you know to
tie in with whatever big movie is that
year but
yeah I can't ride I know there was an
exorcist one but I can't think of this
but yeah they were like really really
good I mean it was like top of the line
[ __ ]
slasher Fred said did you guys ever see
that movie called the worst witch you
know what I was thinking about doing a
video on that like for on my other
channel I guess it's too late now maybe
I can do it next year but um yeah I saw
that several times when I was growing up
and uh that was the one with Tim Curry
right because I know there was one that
was called the worst witch that I'm
pretty sure had Tim Curry in it and then
there was another one that was similar
or in my mind it's similar that was
called something else but it was also
like about a witch like a high school
girl that was like a witch I can't
remember what it was now
I can't remember what it was
uh grafter said scare actors get paid 15
an hour at Horror Nights in Michigan
good side hustle money if you like
acting like a zombie or a Mad Doctor I
have thought about like when I was
younger I had thought about doing
because they were always looking for
people to come there like for Halloween
Horror Nights and they're like hey do
you mind like laying in a coffin and
getting covered with real live rats and
I was like hey I could do that
um but I just never I was too lazy to
like drive over because I think I was
still living in Daytona at that point so
it would have been like too far but it
sounded like fun though and honestly
like every single documentary that I
ever watched because they do a lot of
documentaries about people that do you
know haunted houses like around this
time of year and it's like that always
looks that always looked so fun that
always just looked like something like
really really fun to do I mean I'm sure
it's not as fun in real life as it looks
you know when you actually have to do it
but it does kind of look fun to like
just kind of dress up as a zombie and
get to like run around like scaring
people all night long I think that'd be
cool and get paid for doing it
um
Karen Lee said did you guys like the
movie Night Flyer yeah
yeah we did
um yeah John Smith said uh I love it
it's a sadly overlooked King adaptation
it needs to be remastered
yeah
they do the aspect ratio is wrong it's
like a TV aspect ratio
just and it had good special effects and
you they look real muddy in the version
that we saw yeah because we saw like an
illegal YouTube one because you can't
stream it anywhere yeah you can't stream
it anymore anywhere
um ask me if I have a tad no I don't
really have a tan
although he was out doing yard work yeah
I was doing your room like not today but
yesterday I think
it's just uh actually I think it's good
there's a red light back here we we have
lights back here sometimes the colors
change
yeah and I think that used to be blue
that one well no well this one this is
the regular color that it is yeah
um but sometimes just because it feels
like it I guess it'll switch into like a
different color I think sometimes what
happens is like I hit this table like
I'll back up in my chair and like hit
the table and like it'll change I don't
think I have a tan but I do have some
color
pretty good
but I don't think you're seeing that's
not what you're seeing on the screen
yeah yeah I don't know it's just it's a
reflection of that light I guess so yeah
because it is kind of like this one over
here is kind of reddish yeah this one
over here like kind of I guess it's kind
of reddish it's red and green but those
two things together are like not and I
have like the ring light too but that I
have that like on the cooler setting to
kind of
balance it out
yeah John Smith said I think the worst
witch is author Jill Murphy settled out
of court with JK Rowling yeah because
now that I haven't seen it in a long
time but I do remember it being very
Harry Potter like
very Harry Potter like
um John Gore said acting like a zombie
or Mad Doctor I feel like an honest God
stop your Mad Doctor depending on the
day
and let's see
Pat Hatfield said we never see the Great
Pumpkin nor know for sure whether in
peanuts it actually is supposed to exist
therefore how can it be a horror icon
not trying to start a fight just asking
yeah it's invisible well I kind of like
that's kind of like deep for a kid's
cartoon because they did like leave it
ambiguous I mean Linus really believed
in it right but you never see it it's
funny because
um when I was watching The Addams Family
Halloween special they had a similar
kind of concept in that except it was
called cousin shy but he was also like
invisible and he would like bring you
presents and [ __ ] like this supposed to
be like Santa Claus but but a Halloween
version which I'm all on board for I
like that idea I like that idea
himself says she's hopefully be able to
come see us this winter
that'd be cool yeah I said come see us
and I was talking about live on the show
because she's online and he says
whatever oh I'll come this way and I
said no right you know come see us
[ __ ] on the show
she probably got better things yeah I
guess she watches all our shows but she
doesn't see him live oh okay
and then Keith [ __ ] sending me
messages private messages [ __ ] you
know or murder Hornets he's in there
going damn those arms are huge damn your
biceps and look at you stop loving over
my arms dude get in the gym you're on
the shed go ahead and take he takes
tests he's losing all he's losing a lot
of weight he's getting back in shape but
you're not hitting the [ __ ] you're
not hitting the weights man like you
should
I could walk you through it man you'd be
[ __ ] He's exact Army so I'm I'm hard
on him you know it's it's [ __ ]
brotherly love
[ __ ] hit the [ __ ] sauce that
[ __ ] get in the goddamn gym man
[ __ ] just grab an easy curl bar
[ __ ] starts thinking some weight
it'll come right back
let's go right there and justice for me
said I think Charlie Brown's voice actor
got arrested for stalking although it
could be wrong oh now [ __ ]
my childhood is ruined no now I'm gonna
have to like look that up
why can't anybody just be [ __ ] cool
just be normal God damn it you don't
gotta do that kind of [ __ ]
Senor stick says Tom has a fan yeah I
got all kinds of fans got all kinds of
fans
it's one of my Straight fans though most
of my other fans are gay
sending me pictures of their [ __ ]
feet and [ __ ] like no dude really you
got some pictures I got feet pictures
before you got feedback dude Ben those
those feet are not cute stop trying to
[ __ ] think show me that your feet are
cute they're not [ __ ] cute well it's
so amazing feet see when you say it it
sounds like a dare yeah some people are
gonna be like oh I have I have awesome
feet I'll show you I'm trying to show me
[ __ ] I mean that would never occur to
me look at my man feet those aren't cute
I haven't got any dick pictures so
that's good at least they're being
respectful they're trying to they're
trying to entice I wish I could stay the
same yeah Jay gets all kinds of dick
pics I haven't got any for a while but
yeah I mean I feel like every woman on
Earth has gotten like [ __ ] unsung
pictures were from India weren't they
um not no not all of them okay not all
of them they're kind of from all over
the world dudes dudes that send dick
pics it's like a universal yeah thing I
don't really get
what are they hoping to accomplish
impressing you
trying to impress you do they not know
how like women work or no I guess not
I mean I guess like guys I I answered my
own question because if they did know
how women worked they wouldn't be
sending dick pics in the first place
well you know they would love a picture
of your titties well see that's what I
mean but before you must want people
then you must want yeah I know that's
what it is yeah like they they are
they're incapable of thinking that other
people are not thinking the same thing
they're thinking
they're they're self-absorbed big
difference that's what it is yeah
foreign
said someone should set uh should send
Tom a picture of their bat wing their
stretched out ball sack
I'm giving these dudes any ideas that's
what I'm saying Senor stick says is vag
picks a thing I'm
I did like sometimes like yeah girls
will send like their boyfriend like hey
my titties or something like that but
it's like I never
unless they're a sex bot or they're or
something they why would they send you
like unsolicited pictures of of your
nakedness I don't Instagram is filled
with sex bots if I ever post any kind of
bodybuilding
photos of myself like I've showed my
progress or anything
I will get I'll get people that I know
comment
and then [ __ ] tons of [ __ ] sex bots
I guess I guess there's a there's some
kind of an AI algorithm that can
recognize the human body
and they're like hey might as well yeah
and it somehow says well the algorithm
says okay we'll send a sex bot to the to
them to that because it's but mostly to
videos and pictures that I've posted of
[ __ ] you know what I mean like my you
know ABS or something you know
and uh what's so funny is how
how the the sex bot
is programmed to portray itself no woman
acts that way no no woman acts that way
it's it's a it's a profile
that is following 200 people
has zero followers and zero posts
and five pictures
of a 18 year old girl
saying she likes the big banana
and that woman writes that way no okay
woman that age is running around
it's in their 50s okay they're
17 and 18 year old girls were not
genetically programmed to go after a
[ __ ] [ __ ] guys in their 50s you
know what I mean so who's answering
these [ __ ] things dumb people
desperate people how is this how does
that system work
but I guess they got people that can't
recognize a sex bot profile
or they just keep hoping they just
they're just hoping maybe that one time
it'll be a real person yeah
like I mean you know as a corollary it's
kind of like one of those emails that
you get yeah that says that you won like
a bunch of money and it always starts
with hello dear yes yes yeah yeah like
who's this isn't English I'm like who
are you yeah someone whose first
language is in English
and then and then like uh
um some of the some of the Bots are a
little bit more sophisticated they'll
send you a DM
and the DM is always like hello dear
yeah
and [ __ ] like who talks like that 20
or 20 year old nines and tens do not
[ __ ] friend you and then send you a
DM no that just doesn't happen they
don't do that that's not female Behavior
so and they wouldn't call you dear
that's like that's like a grandma thing
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] no what are they
talking about
you can stop it
it's just what you think they would have
figured that out by now no but I guess
it works enough times that they don't
have to like well there aren't sort
their [ __ ] out I guess there aren't any
humans involved
it's just I'm kind of thinking probably
not I think it's AI algorithms and just
a bunch of computers and it can sit
there and work for days and maybe get
three suckers a day
that's yeah and that would be it's I
mean it's got to be worth it otherwise
it would it wouldn't do it anymore right
otherwise you wouldn't get that many
right because I get them too and I'm
like okay
but just like I get like junk emails
about you know uh making my dick hard
yeah and I'm like do you know something
I don't know or
why are you sending me the weirdest
the weirdest sex bots
I ever saw came off of uh
uh what was it
Facebook Instant Messenger
this was about five or six years ago
you'd get a direct message
from somebody you weren't friended you
weren't even friended to this person
and it would be like I'm right here and
it would show you it was it would say
I'm right here and then show you a
location on Google Earth right it would
be like a
restaurant
or a hotel
and what it was is it was announcing to
you and it was all in your area
yeah and what it was doing it was
showing you where hookers were yeah
that was the weirdest [ __ ]
but that stopped that was only around
for a couple weeks yeah I guess I guess
well because there are some apps because
some people like you know they when they
go places they like to check in and like
you know they know where you are because
of your phone and everything like that
so they had some ones but I think they
did they like pass some laws or
somewhere you had to like kind of keep
that [ __ ] tight or whatever you know
where we're working popping up all the
time and you're not even friended to
this person it's just a random message
I'm right here and it would show you and
it wasn't sure
it would just show you a location and it
would be like you know come meet me you
know and it was um downtown Sanford yeah
we kept that kept hitting a lot and it
was like um she's down at Chantels
having some shrimp no it wasn't Chantels
it was over where um that's where I
would be you know that thing that's uh
it was like a not a
and I was not an IHOP
you know how when we're on the
mainstream we're go we're going to uh
we're going to uh
it's like we're going to mannequins
uh-huh
and you go through that last
intersection and you're now in downtown
Stanford on the left about a half a mile
in it was near where
those restaurants are in that when one
bungalow
there's like a little Mall filled with
restaurants on the left
have you seen that place I had a yeah I
know what you're talking about in there
okay in there yeah yeah I know you're
talking there there was a hooker oh okay
in there yeah
which you wouldn't think there'd be one
in there what are you talking about
hookers are everywhere well you it's
well no you go there and you won't
associate that with [ __ ] hookers
but now you will but yeah yeah you kind
of what now now we're gonna wear Waffle
House in the middle is that a hooker
yeah yeah
I'm not judging Girl Gotta Mega money
somehow
if you went down there how could you
find her
I guess you talk to her through the app
yeah that's probably what it is
yeah where are you at you had to walk
yeah where are you yeah where are you at
yeah
which one are you
yeah oh [ __ ] Norma
that's a double bagger right there
sorry that's me grafter said uh boobs
are beautifully shaped and a delight to
look at the vags looks like an ax wound
that happens no well no I mean well
genitalia are not uh aesthetically that
pleasing really I'm gonna [ __ ]
disagree with everything
yeah I mean it depends it depends no it
depends no they've got some boobs are
nice boobs are nice no
they got some [ __ ] Monumental
cuchachas out there
they got some girls are just gifted
most women Well everybody's got to be
good at something yeah most women are
most women I would just say you know
there's nothing bad about it they're
like yeah yeah that's cool that's good
enough but good if that'll work like
it's not funny looking or anything
it's not funny but no they got some
women they're just [ __ ] you know no
where are you just kind of like it's
just yeah it's a pretty looking [ __ ]
snacks
you know
yeah
and demonetized
that's all right nobody watches these
anyway other than the people that are
like yeah regulars right so yeah so I'm
not really all that word I'm not worried
about it though no so I got this I gotta
disagree man they got yeah I mean that's
the thing but I'm just saying in general
yeah in general it's that's not usually
unless that's your thing because I know
that is well you know there's people
that are in defeat and there's people
into like all all different body parts
so it's just never something that really
occurred to me like wow
what a what a nice looking cooch that
girl has oh no they're out there you
know what I mean I can point them out
I bet you can yeah there's some pros out
there that are just [ __ ] hell yeah
like I said I've seen nice boobs I've
seen like nice boobs but it's like I
don't know I guess that never occurred
to me yeah no they got some girls out
there that are just gifted
yeah so they were talking about uh sex
spots and Senior stick says maybe that
one time it won't be a dude yeah right I
mean yeah
uh let's see doo doo doo
oh wait I saw something funny up here oh
John Smith said maybe the AI is just
trying to reproduce demon seed style
maybe that's what it is
uh And Justice For Me said good friend
do you want our sweepstakes please claim
your price immediately yeah they always
they always say like deer or I think
I've had a couple did I have a couple
that said darling but I kind of feel
like deer is the is the one I'm like
nobody
I just feel like that's people like in
other countries and they think oh well
because people start used to start
letters back in the old days with D or
so and so that it's like oh that's how
you refer to people that's how you like
talk to people when you're writing the
bladder I'm like nobody talks like that
the whole deer starting something off
with deer or something that I always
associate that with Chinglish that's
Chinese English well not back in the old
days like because back in the old days
but now yeah it's because because
um
Koreans were the same way Koreans are
always real upset about which form of
English that they're gonna [ __ ] learn
because
in in the East everything is a hierarchy
social hierarchy so something everything
has to be higher than something else so
which is the highest version of English
you know oh we're not going to try to
learn English that's spoken in New York
oh no that's that's low class oh we're
going to learn it something in England
but you know but there's [ __ ] 20
different versions of English English
and England in London alone you know
[ __ ] says I mean you could go 30
miles and they have a completely
different accent so which one are they
gonna [ __ ] choose to be the real
English the real high class English well
some [ __ ] from [ __ ] Shakespearean
[ __ ] from [ __ ] you know a good 500
years ago or you know they're gonna
they're gonna pick some Victorian [ __ ]
from the 1800s thinking that that's the
real English
because that's like the more exalted
it's like yeah like on the ground nobody
talks like that nobody talks and people
didn't really talk like that I don't
think back then most people everybody
had a different Regional accent yeah
it's always been like that like
languages are always more complicated
that's why they're like you know that's
why it's hard to explain that to say
like a Korean because I got into
conversations with that when I was
living in Korea and it would be the same
for China and Japan it's a similar
hierarchy-based [ __ ] mindset that's
why you can't really date those girls or
not unless not if you're a sane person
um because everything has to everything
boils down to what's higher than this
really very status oriented super status
oriented
Senor 6 asks when is hurricane season
hurricane season in Florida no it's not
no I thought it was over uh-uh hurricane
season hey I'm I'm over here I know when
hurricane season hurricane season in
Florida is from June the 1st to November
the 30th okay
September and October are the worst
though it's unusual to get ones in
November but not impossible I remember
that's happened before if it's like
super hot when you're but yeah hurricane
season is actually not over until
November 30th and I always remember that
because that is also my sister's
birthday
um Zach says all I know is Norwegian men
have amazing looking dicks yeah I I kind
of feel like I don't know I feel like
maybe like most dicks are ugly like no
offense but
um I feel like I've probably seen a
couple more like okay looking dicks and
I've seen like okay looking snatches I
don't know it's stripping I don't know I
haven't really thought about it all that
much clearly
um John Smith said I start emails with
dear so and so well I kind of feel like
if it's a business communication like if
you're sending like um like a cover
letter like with a resume or something I
think that's still the preferred like
formal letter thing but normally I mean
unless it's that I don't like I don't
even usually say the person's name to be
honest with you I just I I like the more
like informal kind of [ __ ] and John
Smith said I'm from Newcastle the
dialect there is barely English
yeah a lot of the stuff that gets made
fun of that Southerners do and say is
actually just really archaic versions of
things of English and uh and certain
kind of like
if I can Irish influence type dialects
and certain things that you know like
card games that were popular and
everything and
like Yonder was that
you might get [ __ ] made fun of in the
north for saying the word like Yonder
but Yonder was like some [ __ ] high
class English [ __ ] so it was ain't
evidently back in the 70s yeah I'd heard
that as well and Yonder were like
[ __ ] real high class but now it's
like right but now that's the redneck
Over Yonder yeah Yonder it ain't missing
that ain't
I'm fascinated by languages
I'm just fat well I don't know it's like
it's very interesting to me like it's I
love
um slang like where slang comes from
like and [ __ ] like that and I kind of
feel like too that even words that we
know of as slang and stuff like that
have been around like a lot longer than
most people realize granther said are
women impressed with big dogs that look
like a baby's arm holding an apple or
would they prefer an average six incher
I think we've said this before but I
kind of feel like it depends more on the
person that it's attached to
than the actual thing you know what I
mean
yeah you could you could be a dude as
[ __ ] seriously blessed but [ __ ]
you're a piece of [ __ ] that's not worth
anything then yeah I mean you might get
like a couple first dates and people
like yeah nice dick or whatever but then
like they're not gonna call you I'm
gonna call you back there nothing so
women like it when women want everything
they want that big ass dick [ __ ]
attached to a [ __ ] dude who's cute
has a full head of hair and that
motherfucker's got to be a billionaire
and then he's got to have a [ __ ]
several Ferraris just you know just I
don't need it you don't need it yeah but
here's the thing Jenny Jenny always
throws herself in the mix and in no way
is she the average woman in absolutely
no way well I know you mean that as an
insult but it's not a compliment
no just Jenny's not really attuned to
average female culture
uh she's her own thing which is one of
the reasons why hair and I are still
together because she's Sane I'm My Own
Thing yeah
most women are [ __ ] crazy
but they're but but they're crazy
because y'all are you know y'all drive
us crazy that's why
[Laughter]
most women are very much at least the
ones that I remembered that I would say
yeah that's a girl girl are into doing
toenails and [ __ ] lots of grooming
and [ __ ] makeup experts and real femi
and uh
um uh designer clothes and
um [ __ ] um you know [ __ ] kind of
shock-like [ __ ] Yuppie type dudes
um
they're a certain way and and they're
kind of narrow band
they don't step outside that little
narrow band of [ __ ] thinking and
um activity and if you ask those girls
they're the real women everybody else
those are [ __ ] fake women you know
basically
so a lot of them are like that
especially in more urban areas back in
the day
you know what I mean like I can
girls that worked in offices and [ __ ]
up in Boston
they're like that
well gosh I might be really hurt if I
absolutely gave a [ __ ] with anybody so
I'm saying I'm telling you
because she's only going to give you her
point of view well I don't like I don't
speak for anybody else I don't know I
just speak for me and for people that
and people that I know that I've known
over the years that's all I can speak
for yeah I I would not presume to like
speak for anyone else because
everybody's different typical American
woman but but this always falls into
certain age groups some certain
socio-economic groups and everything
that's going to be different
across the board but a lot of the
[ __ ]
girls that consider themselves to really
be the [ __ ] you know I mean the ones
that they're [ __ ] You Know Rich dudes
are going after they're
they're a [ __ ] pain in the ass man
yeah I don't know because I knew some
girls like that in high school and I
don't like them that's yeah you're
getting on my nerves yeah
they're kind of like trophy wives type
thing
and they get fake degrees and [ __ ]
And Justice For Me said I've I've been
made fun of for saying I reckon but its
derivation is British yeah and the thing
is when I was in the UK like people said
that all the time like I kind of feel
like maybe in the U.S like it's
considered like a maybe like a redneck
Eternal phrase but I heard British
people saying it all the time so
I say it
I say that I say y'all I say all kind of
stuff
like that well like I said I grew up in
the South but the thing about it is that
my dad's side of the family are southern
they're from Tennessee but my mom's side
of the family was slightly more Northern
they were like Baltimore or DC area
so they didn't really have like a
Southern accent so much
so I kind of got
like both sort of things so that's why I
don't even though I grew up in the South
I don't like have I don't think I have
like a super southern accent but I do
say Southern things like y'all and
everything
yeah and John Smith said I reckon sounds
fine to me yeah that's to me that
doesn't read as
all that is like rednecky sounding
you know yeah a lot of the so-called
redneck stuff people up north go home
that's a rednecky ass [ __ ] if you
actually go through the history it's
actually real British very British and
very archaic and no longer in use in in
the UK
you know they do say reckon though yeah
they still say reckon yeah I've heard
but ain't was aristocratic British
aristocratic stuff from like
16 1700s I think
Pat Hatfield said women want everything
hell I guess I don't stand a chance you
shouldn't say things like that because
like I said it's not women are a hive
mind too like they're there's different
ones it's just it's weird because dudes
don't seem to have a problem like you
know considering other dudes like as
individuals but like women they just
want to like say oh women want this and
that the other thing I'm like they're
just individual people just like you
can't make sense so when you're seeing
it from a guy's point of view because
he's trying to get a girlfriend
so he's fighting against a mass of of
these women
in society to try to get one of them so
they all started kind of be like these
women you know so they start having an
idea of US versus them type yeah I know
even though that's not exactly what it
is it's just that you kind of fall into
the habit of going these women are
[ __ ] crazy they're othering that yeah
yeah there's well they can't get in yeah
they're trying to get in but they can't
because unfortunately the average guy is
not good enough nowadays
that's not what they're looking for most
of the women are fighting for the top 10
percent of the men of the men of their
age group
so a lot of them are getting left out
and then they're becoming demoralized
they're gaining a bunch of weight
they're getting too far off into video
games and they're giving up and they
porn is a problem I believe
we didn't have easy access to porn when
we were kids [ __ ] grafters tell you
all about it gotta find some magazines
in the woods could be good enough man
you're gonna have to go out like a cave
Madison magazines in the woods Pizza who
the [ __ ] was this it was leaving all the
magazines in the woods everybody found
some now the kids were taking them to
the woods I know that's what it said
the the [ __ ] sup man I forgot what I
was gonna say porn porn yeah
so easy access to porn dudes the same
well [ __ ] it all right you know
why pursue women is too much too it's
too much trouble too much trouble but at
least they're taking themselves out of
the dating pool so that's good
yeah it's not good because then you have
chicks like Sophie who guys aren't
beating down her door because those
dudes are all jacking off
you know
so then they got to go on them damn
dating sites we were talking about that
earlier I mean so and those dating sites
are [ __ ] toxic okay
they kind of warp the mind if you ask me
she likes them
like that's not how you meet people I
don't think I ever went on one of those
that's not how you meet people I mean
I've been on them like
but I never I don't think I ever had
like a profile in there not that I
remember no [ __ ] you don't want to do
that because I can
you're setting yourself up for failure
um finding a girlfriend out of a dating
app is kind of like trying to find a car
out of a damn junkyard all right there's
dude
the good women in there the dudes are
[ __ ] running through them and every
time you see her she's already kind of
Tainted you're like man yeah I met her
through this site but how many other
dudes was she [ __ ] through this site
before me and if I make a mistake she's
just gonna go back into that site and go
[ __ ] some other dudes so you're not
gonna the dude's not gonna invest in
them
so it's going to be hookup sites what
they it's really what they are well I
think that's why it's better that they
have ones that are specifically for that
because that's at least honest yeah but
that's a waste of time because there's
no guarantee if you're a guy that you're
gonna hook up with this chick go on a
date and get laid
I've always been a big Advocate and I
don't [ __ ] mean to sound crude
because I admitted to I use this myself
when I was a kid
go for the escorts
it's a better quality woman you already
know she's a hoe she's already agreed to
work with you she's going to give you
exactly what you want and you're not
gonna have to dump her you're gonna walk
right out and never have to see her
again
and it's gonna be a good leg well isn't
that the isn't that the whole
um point of like having escorts I think
there's like well the payment isn't for
the sex the payment is for them to leave
afterwards
[ __ ] alone right and the thing is is
that and some dudes like that I'm not
judging I'm not judging if you go on a
dating site you're gonna have to pretend
that you're on a date
and a date is basically a job interview
you're not going to get the job because
she's going to interview and interview
and interview and interview and you're
going to pay for
save your [ __ ] money
just go to an escort service
well I mean if that's really kind of
like all you want yeah that's all those
dudes want that's what I'm saying if you
just want to get laid then go to the
professional you'll get the girl you can
get the porn star of your dream whatever
whatever porn star yeah it's
transactional but if that's all you want
then that's what it is that's what it is
on the dating side anyway
it they're Horrors basically
okay who she went to go work with Okay
he runs all those sites all right and he
he runs escort services too
he approaches
the women that he meets on dating apps
as low end hookers
he goes to the date with him
before they order he says I like you
what would it cost for me to actually
have sex with you and if she gets
insulted he leaves
she wants to eat make her pay for the
meal if she gives him a price then they
[ __ ]
actually have the meal and he just pays
her and has sex with her
and he says half of them give a price
off those damn dating sites
and he says well and if they get upset
they go what are you here for
you know why'd you come here with me
this is what you're here for right to
have sex what's it going to cost me and
half of them will give the price
so just go right for the throat don't
try to whine and dine some chick off a
[ __ ] dating site man just go [ __ ]
are we gonna [ __ ] or not and how much do
I have to pay you well like I said if
that's all you want then right then go
right without a transaction because
otherwise you're just wasting everyone
you're wasting everybody's time because
the thing about it is that right
um you know if someone was because I
know like
in a lot of ways like a lot of people
meet people online nowadays like
Injustice for me just said I've been
with my girlfriend since 2009 met her on
Plenty of Fish uh which I've heard is
actually one of the better ones I don't
know I haven't been on there but um said
it worked out well but I'm aware of the
horror stories yeah yeah so I feel like
there's a lot of Horrors and it's always
most of those dating sites all those and
even like the affair site Ashley Madison
and all that stuff it's always like 90
dudes uh eight percent sex bots and two
percent actual women
so uh so there's kind of like a a thing
where
there's a lot of dudes on there and
there's not really a lot of women so
there's like some and they're like
competing for all of them but I just
kind of feel like even women that are
legitimately like on dating sites
because some women are because I've
known some that that did that but I mean
you don't want to waste their time
either if you if she wants an actual
like boyfriend or husband or something
and then this dudes up shows up and he
just wants to [ __ ] right that's like not
I'm not saying that either of those
people are wrong I'm just saying that
that reality is that I'm just saying
that that's like not gonna work out
because they both want different things
like like I said if you just want to
hook up then go to a site and do that
and say that yeah like I said just be
honest up front like it's like look I'm
not looking for a relationship I just
you know I just want to have like a [ __ ]
buddy or I just want something like that
like if you're honest then I think that
will work out much better for you and
honestly if you just come out and say
hey I'm looking for a long-term
relationship I'm not like you know out
to just like [ __ ] anybody or whatever
then say that most of those people on
their sites especially the women are
front you know a lot of them don't want
a boyfriend they just want to be dated
they wanted people to buy because Scott
said he got sick of paying for the meal
because that's what they just wanted a
free meal but yeah free food free food
I'll take that and they just want free
food over and over again so before they
even order he asks how much it's gonna
cost to get in the pants and she's oh
I'm not doing it okay bye it just leaves
her there
[Laughter]
but he's wasting money
he's wasted let's see here's the thing
though it's like do we know that I mean
like I said he's married I know he is
you know see he he doesn't want a
girlfriend
he just but like I said all I'm
advocating is that everybody should be
honest about what they want oh yeah yeah
like I said if all you want is to [ __ ]
then say that there's nothing wrong with
that nothing at all but it but just
don't don't use like these like
underhanded tactics like don't get
people there under false pretenses
because you're just wasting everyone's
time yeah well he said that he kept
doing the dinner date thing and uh
he kept getting used like he was a simp
because they're those girls are playing
simps basically and he so he cut the
simp possibility out of it he just
wanted to know what's it gonna cost and
if it's if it's not for sale he hasn't
won
and you've seen it you've seen it
yourself the ones he shows up with
but uh most of them are for sale or he
said half about half well I just know
that one that one was yeah she seemed
nice but she was seemed also seemed a
little bit crazy yeah
um like not in a bad way but yeah crazy
you know um but then the um I was just
kind of like alrighty she was for sale
well I know that but I'm just saying
that like she I mean she was nice enough
she was nice enough
um granther said uh the Bunny Ranch in
Reno Nevada flies in porn stars every
weekend for customers average price is
two thousand dollars for an hour worth
it yeah no rip off two thousand dollars
come on nobody's actually getting all
that [ __ ] money well and honestly
like porn stars they I mean unless
you're super famous in movies and stuff
which I kind of feel like most of them
aren't anymore that's how they make all
their money is going around to like
strip clubs and you know and uh you know
the Bunny Ranch and stuff like that and
like doing like special appearances yeah
this is uh this is what you do
when your favorite porn star comes
around to do a show with the at your
local strip club
try to get get hold of management see if
she's got security with her in the
management and ask her you know is she
going to do any any uh like private
meetings after after her shift you know
and they're either gonna say yes or no
but they're going to say yeah and
they're going to collect a group of guys
and you're going to meet up at the hotel
that she's staying at that's what's
going to happen here
well yeah that's kind of like the thing
that they do yeah it's going it's not
gonna cost that much two or three
hundred probably
that's cheaper that's cheaper than a day
I mean I wouldn't know I haven't been
there a long time so but I mean two
thousand dollars a night that's
ridiculous I know prices have gone up
and stuff but
that's a lot I can't imagine
I can't imagine a single person I would
want to have sex with that that badly
you're not a man well I know that but
I don't know I kind of feel like even if
even if I had two thousand dollars which
I don't
I'm like I'm sure I can think of many
better things to spend it on than that
you know what I'm saying uh Senora stick
said Ashley Madison is about Mary
cheating yeah that's kind of the whole
and like I said I don't look I don't
know your life I don't know what people
do like I I don't have a problem with
um you know something like Ashley
Madison existing uh just to facilitate
they're like hey some people have I you
know I don't facilitate cheating on your
spouse but a lot of people have open
marriages or like open relations and
they're like and they're fine with it
which like I said as long as everybody
knows is on the same page then I don't
have a problem with it you know what I
mean so I don't have a problem with with
sites like that existing you know what
I'm saying because like I said they're
just trying to facilitate hey like me
and my wife have an open marriage and
like you know when I can go and she can
do go and do whatever and you're like
looking for hookups like fine whatever
but
I don't know it's just I I kind of feel
like
I was reading an article about Ashley
Madison this is probably this is
probably like a year ago or something
like that but they were talking about I
think they got didn't they get in
trouble I mean it's been a while since I
read the article but didn't they get in
trouble because they found out that like
almost all of the
women on there were were fake accounts
like there weren't really that many
what's with that tracks I mean I'm sure
there were some real women on there but
there's just not that many and I kind of
feel like a lot of dating sites
particularly ones that are hook up heavy
like or that are skewed more toward that
kind of thing
um usually I think that is kind of like
a magnet for fake accounts like sex bots
and it's almost and it's usually like
all dudes now you have like more of a
balanced thing on something that's more
like somebody mentioned like eHarmony or
something like that which is a lot more
geared toward like long-term
relationships or marriage or something
like and that's fine too like you can
have all different kind of things for
whatever it is you're looking for but I
kind of feel like the ones that are
geared more toward hookups
um that one those ones are usually
overwhelmingly men and most of the women
that you see on their like fake accounts
are fake accounts or their escorts so
not all of them but I kind of feel like
that's the percentages yeah there's a
house how does porn make any money
turning tricks
doing live shows
those girls are all hookers
well I would recommend and I know this
is like several years old at this point
but I would recommend reading uh Jenna
Jameson's autobiography
um it's actually really good and it's
actually really really interesting and
she kind of goes a lot into that she's
like you know even back then like Jenna
Jameson and she was like a huge star and
everything and she's like well porn
stars
um that's not I mean yeah they make
their money doing movies but that's the
damn that's kind of like yeah that's not
where they make most of their money
they're like if you're a name of any
kind in porn then how you make most of
your money is going around and doing
personal appearances and like escort
service stuff like that or like you know
coming and like stripping like live and
people come paying to come and see you
and stuff that's where they make most of
their money not So Much from the movies
yeah the porn is a demo yeah essentially
that's kind of like yeah that's how you
get famous and like you get people
coming to see you like I said it's just
like any other fandom you know what I
mean which is a weird thing to say but
it's essentially the same thing so
they're gonna come this like oh my God
she's my favorite so I'm gonna come in
like see her when she's at this strip
club or whatever as far as dating apps
though I guess uh me and Jenny are Gen X
and
we didn't grow up dating that way it was
always through friends networking and
through nightclubs
so like for instance
if me and Jen ever broke up we wouldn't
need dating services or dating apps our
next boyfriends or girlfriends would be
people we already know
yeah because we know mostly we know it
we know a lot of people and they're
gonna or we know people that know those
people
me and Jenny would get snapped up by
other people quick
and that's just the name of the game
Yeah well yeah and that's what I mean
it's like I'm not really I don't really
worry about it and honestly it's not and
I don't think it's just because I'm old
because I don't
I know that like a lot of people do meet
people understand and honestly I I met
like a really cool guy that I dated for
a while like on Facebook like not you
know it wasn't a dating service but he
was just like friended me and like we
started talking and like blah blah and
then we just like went out but it
doesn't have the stigma of a dating
service for us so not the same yeah that
was just Facebook but other than that
like I just feel like everybody
I don't know well I don't know it's not
that weird because I guess I met my
first husband through
um through um not well not internet
because it was before that because it
was 90s but a pen pal service because he
was in another country but so that's
kind of like the old school version
but other than that everybody else I've
dated I've met like in person pretty
much other than the one guy on Facebook
but I don't think I've ever have I ever
put a
I'm trying to think if I've ever put a
put a profile on a data I don't think I
ever have
I don't think I ever have I don't know
what senior sticks it does not that I
remember where
he is asking if you're a dude I don't
know oh because
um I don't understand I don't understand
the reference
wait Jenny's on the internet does that
mean she's dude oh because no because I
said I didn't say on the internet I just
said on uh on hookup apps yeah I kind of
feel like most like I said most of the
apps that are geared toward hookups are
usually very very
Man heavy but so like any like most of
the women that you see on there are
probably like fake accounts or escorts
here's the thing
if you're a [ __ ] Chad you're not
gonna be on damn dating sites
not really
just not
I mean I'm gonna be so networked
I feel like we've I feel like we've
talked about this before maybe it's
easier for us because because of our
generation the way we grew well not only
Our Generation but also because we're
you know because of the Golf Scene and
like we kind of and it's small ish and
we're known and we kind of like know
everybody and we've been around a long
time so it's just kind of like I mean
networking I think is a lot more
important like yeah I mean it's much
easier to meet somebody through friends
who already know you and are like hey I
know this person or like you already
kind of know that person like a couple
of degrees separated or they're already
negotiating with strength
you know what I'm talking about and you
already know that they have something in
common with you and [ __ ] like that big
difference between somebody's seen a
picture of you on some [ __ ] dating
site and then them seeing you walk into
a [ __ ] club [ __ ] decked out
looking cool as a [ __ ]
everybody [ __ ] greeting you say oh
you're back you know it's a very
different impression the first
impressions are very different
and it's really really hard to that's I
think that was one of the re even though
I'm a writer and I feel like I express
myself better in writing but trying to
like get across your whole
thing in writing like on a dating site
like writing a profile I just can't even
imagine like what like what I would say
like to get across my [ __ ]
thing that I have going on which I don't
even know what it is so so was talking
about how guys suck at texting and that
[ __ ] they don't know how to text
that's true and I'm like going but I'm
[ __ ] laughing and I'm like I don't
really know how to text either no you
don't but you know I but that's that's
nothing for a while like when like
before we kind of start because I was
still living in Daytona like when we
kind of first started like hanging out
and like sometimes it wasn't so much
text but we'd talk like over instant
messenger or whatever and like sometimes
um I thought that you were mad at me
because you were so like terse and I
feel like a lot of dudes are like that
like they don't even bother to like
capitalize words or like use proper
grammar or anything like that and I'm
just like are they mad at me because
they're just kind of like so yeah no but
you know what I mean it's just it's that
kind of thing
and it's but it is harder to like get
stuff across than text I get that yeah
well I was oh I never I never [ __ ]
hunted females over [ __ ]
over [ __ ] cell phones I was more
you're in a [ __ ] bar and I walk in
and taking my motorcycle helmet off and
throwing it to the [ __ ] bartender and
her and her going you want a tequila and
everybody's going oh you're back you're
back you know that's the impression none
of this [ __ ] electronic [ __ ] you
know what I mean it's just okay in your
face real life situation you know that's
that generally like I said I think that
that's generally is better I just so I
always say like and like I said it's
at this point because everybody is so
online now like now it just seems like
churlish an old person-ish to like say
oh you can't meet people online because
a lot of people do
um you know an idea and it works out
fine but I'm just saying I think it's
easier to like go out and do like go out
and like join a club like that has
something to do with like [ __ ] that
you're interested in yeah you know like
I said I mean you know we're in the god
scene so we go to the goth bars and like
you know we know all those people and
like we go to like event to like that
and so you already know that you have
something in common with those people
like before you even meet them you know
what I mean and the longer you hang
around I mean you know maybe it's we
have an advantage because we're old and
we've been around forever so like I said
we know everybody or we know somebody
that knows that person you know what I
mean like we know pretty much everybody
and so it's so it's kind of like a lot
easier for us but we've been because
we've been established for such a long
time and we're involved with creating
these events yeah and Engineering them
in different ways so you know bar owners
are dealing with us and
DJs and you know the families and wives
of DJs and the children of DJs and
um people that have been around Forevers
and and it's all
transgenerational too you know you have
people that'll be young enough to be our
kids who are hanging out with us like
thinking which is great I kind of love
that I love that they're hanging out
with us like we're cool as [ __ ] you know
but even though it's like you could you
could be our children well actually they
are our friends yeah they're our friends
but that doesn't matter because I
remember when I was in high school I
[ __ ] wanted to hang out with rock
stars would be the same age difference
right and this when I was looking at
when I was a kid look at it [ __ ]
dudes [ __ ] like from [ __ ] Iron Man
or Motley Crue or whatever they were my
parents generation they were my parents
age yeah but but I didn't see him as my
parents so like no no my parents are
lame cm.c and that's what I mean if
that's what I mean when I call people
like when I [ __ ] on people for being
like grandpa or like old people or stuff
I don't mean you're old in age I mean
you're old like that like you're old in
Attitude yeah because I've known like
some people that were older than me that
are cool as [ __ ] and I've known some
people that are like 25 that suck so it
doesn't have anything to do with how old
you actually are we've had we've had
people that would be our children's age
kind of put moves on us a little bit
yeah she's had young guys that'd be
young enough to be her
son [ __ ] interested in [ __ ] you
know there's a lot of [ __ ] it's a little
weird it's weird but it's a little weird
yeah I remember that happened to me a
couple of times like at Old Eye bar yep
like yeah I had one guy like and I was
just kind of I thought it was kind of
funny because I was like he was clearly
like much younger than me and I was just
like and I thought it was sort of like
how old are you yeah I didn't say how
old are you son but I wanted to but and
he told me and I was just kind of like
should I tell him that I that I could be
your mom or he knew no he knew he knew a
little bit weird he knew well I told uh
Michael from a starry night
it never occurs to me that he's like
much younger than me so they had played
a show and then they came to ibar after
and like I was talking to Michael or
whatever and he said something about
what he said something about being born
in like 1990 and I was and I laughed
yeah and I like I froze yeah and I was
like you realize I graduated from high
school in 1990 right like the same year
that you were born I was like I'm a dude
I could be your mom yeah and he was like
that's okay
it was funny though I didn't realize in
our scene nobody sees it that way nobody
sees the nobody sees the age differences
that way not really it's it's kind of
cool like that that's one of the things
I like about a [ __ ] tribe A Tribe of
people in its own culture and we're all
just kind of
I don't want to see we're all equals
because there's a hierarchy kind of
involved in it it's just that but not as
much as yeah not really well I mean
there is depending on how long you've
been around like economic stuff too how
much money you have is also kind of
[ __ ] important too because some
people don't have a [ __ ] pot to visit
um
some people do some people are unstable
you know it was like you know Nick and
Aaliyah they didn't really have anything
they were really cool but they looked up
to us because we had [ __ ] then they
broke up
yeah and they were all young too yeah
they were really but they were real that
was the cool thing is like they were
easily like young enough to be our kids
but they were into all the same [ __ ]
that we were in even the old music and
everything man they were like so they
were like oh my God like Joy Division
and Christian death and they were coming
at it
from a perspective because I mean you
know we've been listening to that for
like [ __ ] 30 years or whatever but
it's like for them it was like new yeah
and it wasn't like we were hanging out
with kids
yeah didn't feel like it's not weird
like that it's that's what I mean it's
like hard to explain because I know how
like I know how like some people might
say it's like oh you know 50 year old
people like hanging out with like 19
year old people but you don't really it
doesn't I don't know you don't really
think of it like that yeah I mean it
kind of occurs you it's like oh they
could be my kid but it's like I don't
know it's not they're not your kids
though they're not your kids you're
right yeah and it's just like that's
just like another person that's into the
same cool [ __ ] as you so that's really
like as far as you think about it and
when they broke up [ __ ] Nick is
making out with [ __ ] A girlfriend of
ours who's [ __ ] your age she's
probably about 50 remember she pulled
his ass into the bathroom and mauled him
yeah and he came out that bathroom man
the bathroom's [ __ ] deadly and
[ __ ] and not the public bathroom it's
the employee at private yeah he came out
with a big old smile on his face man all
kind of shenanigans go on in there yeah
it was like that old lady [ __ ] took
care of you dude he's like man I don't
have to do that I eat a drink
now she's a cute
cute older goth chick that
you probably wouldn't know how old she
was and when you saw her I've shown her
before I kind of feel like that she's
she's taken right now she's got a
boyfriend and I don't want to embarrass
anybody but yeah don't do that yeah
but yeah it's just I don't know she uh
she was 50 and he's probably he turned
he's 21. he's 21 or 22. yeah
so like I said that's whatever
as long as everybody's cool with it
yeah yeah she totally is
she's awesome though yeah and her
boyfriend is younger the one yeah
because he's younger yeah he's 30 maybe
huh I don't know how old he is actually
like I said I never thought about it
it's just kind of like I don't know
everybody comes there and it's like you
know they're all gossed out and they
look fabulous and everything and you're
not really worried about oh that's that
person's old or that person's
you know seniors asked me Tom and Jen if
you made dating profiles would you match
probably not probably not
which is one of the reasons that it's
like yeah we're like a lot different
we're a lot different yeah so I don't
know if they I don't know if they want
we're in we wear a lot of the same
Styles and we're in the same
Aesthetics a lot of times but no me and
Jen are [ __ ] almost opposites um but
that's not bad not bad really if we were
exactly the same we'd probably get on
each other's nerves a lot worse probably
probably
you don't have to be the same
yeah yeah I mean I don't know it depends
what it is like some ways it helps but
yeah you don't want the person to be
like another just another version of you
because that would be like weird and
you're just [ __ ]
in an echo chamber yeah pretty much
Jeff yard said I agree with Jenny as
long as all parties are on the same page
nobody's getting hurt then awesome I
totally respect sex workers and honest
living is an honest living yeah like I
said if they want to do that
hey I wouldn't want to do that but some
people like it so yeah I just don't like
deception though well that's what I'm
saying like as long as as long as
nobody's being deceived into like what
the what the outcome for everyone's
gonna be then just like I said just be
honest there there are women there are
women out there that are basically sex
workers but haven't admitted admitted it
to themselves
ah
um apps let me go get uh this these
Zach says I was born in 1997. how old
were you guys then
1997. I was 18.
wait a minute
25 I was 25.
yeah
because I graduated from high school in
1990.
so yeah I would have been 25.
1997 I don't even remember what happened
in 1997 to be honest with you
kind of like I don't know I feel like I
remember some [ __ ] from the 90s but not
much
the 90s were so lame
that's why I was talking to
I was talking to a guy yesterday like in
downtown like the guy that uh works at
the at the new bar that they're opening
and uh he was talking about I think he
was I I'm not sure how old he was like I
said I don't ask people because it's
rude but um he seemed to have like grown
up in the 90s so I'm assuming that he's
probably like at least a decade younger
than me maybe more
um but because he was talking about zema
and everything and I was like I remember
that [ __ ] but he was like saying how oh
the mom jeans are coming back and I was
like yeah what the [ __ ] is that all
about like
those high-waisted jeans like I thought
we we had established that like the low
like the hip hooker kind of stuff like
looks better why is the mom jeans coming
back that makes everyone's ass look flat
so I don't know whatever
whatever I guess everybody just got sick
of the other thing and they're like okay
now we have to like go the other
direction but yeah he was talking about
mom jeans coming back and I'm just like
all right I didn't like him the first
time and I don't like him this time
either
um Zach says uh it would also probably
be boring as [ __ ] to be someone just
like you too you run out of [ __ ] to talk
about so fast yeah I mean like I said I
guess it would depend because I mean you
kind of want somebody that's sort of
into the same [ __ ] as you so because
it's like you don't want to
you know be in a completely different
[ __ ] because then you wouldn't want to
do anything together because it'd be
like oh that's lame and it's like no I
don't want to do that that's lame you
know what I mean but as long as you have
some overlap I think it's okay but I
mean usually other than that like as you
probably see like on a lot of our
reviews and stuff I'm kind of much more
I don't know like I think Tom has some
like kind of geeky stuff too like about
certain things even though I don't think
he would call it that but I'm a lot more
like geeky about horror I'm a lot more
like enthusiastic about
um I don't know just kind of like horror
[ __ ] you know cool Halloween kind of
[ __ ] like all that kind of stuff whereas
he's much more like not like he's too
cool for that kind of stuff so it's that
kind of thing
uh John Gore said gold digging is a
profession in itself yeah I guess
I guess like I said I'm just
horrible like an honest person I don't
really like deceiving people I like
everybody knowing what's
what's going on what's expected of
everybody I don't really like I'm not a
good liar I'm just I'm not good at that
kind of stuff it's just too much work
it's too much I'm too lazy I'm too lazy
for deception that's what it is I don't
want to have to keep track of all the
lies I've told and who I've told them to
it just seems like too much trouble
as you know I have other things to do
and I just I don't have time for it uh
Jenny are you still a whole fan um yeah
I don't know if I would have called
myself a fan but I liked that first
album I don't think I bought anything
else of theirs but that's about it
it is very 90s like I said I'm not
I don't know I think I've talked about
this before
um
I wasn't a fan of like the 90s as a
decade and I'm not saying that there was
a cool [ __ ] that happened in the 90s
there was it was a ton of cool [ __ ] that
had in the 90s but I kind of feel like
the 90s there was just something about
the 90s I just didn't love even even
though you would think that that was
because like I said I graduated in 1990
so that was like my college Years and
all this other kind of stuff and so like
I had a good time I went to a lot of
shows and stuff like that but
I don't know I just there was something
about it I didn't really like and I
can't really put my finger on what it is
I kind of feel like horror movies got
kind of sucky they all went PG-13 and
they all just like let's remake all
these like slashers except with prettier
people and like not in less blood and
I'm like
I don't like that they remade a bunch of
stuff the music started sucking like
right around the mid 90s
I didn't love you know the whole thing
after uh you know like Nirvana got real
famous and then like all the grunge
thing I didn't love that you know
alternative music like went mainstream I
didn't love that
everything was like now then they
started making movies like oh look we
have a goth aesthetic in the movie like
with the Matrix and all that I was like
murder harness is in there
saying the mid 90s was [ __ ] his Peak
nah you could your Peak can be anywhere
man you can make a comeback you're
starting to [ __ ] look good bro just
stay on that [ __ ] he's another man of my
thinking okay I'm gonna run to the
bathroom and I was saying earlier I said
[ __ ] all that dating site [ __ ] if you're
just trying to get laid
your money's better spent just on going
to Pro all right
well
murder Hornets he works in Mexico he
crosses that border all the time
he'll go to the damn Mexican brothel
he'll pull this [ __ ] phone out and
start showing me the girls and get me to
pick one out
pick one out for him
and it's a lot more efficient
and them girls are professionals and
they're friendly and uh they're going to
get right to the point and it's
guaranteed it's guaranteed
it's like it was in Korea when I was
there
it's just uh
it's a more honest you know
okay
Zach
was saying he had a
show topic suggestion
famous horror video games that's a good
idea
he's going yeah [ __ ] zag Zone it's
only 35 35 [ __ ] dollars
all right
that's less than what a [ __ ] meal for
two costs
no woman can compete with that no no
date can compete with that
and then you have to deal with her
you're like oh thank you baby that's
[ __ ] great I'll be back next week
maybe I'll see you or that one maybe
I'll get that one or that one next time
but I'll see you next week
more tailored to her man's taste you
know
okay uh
horror video games
let me get my [ __ ] I lost my [ __ ]
here hold on
the one that comes to mind man was
Splatterhouse
remember Splatterhouse
I [ __ ] love that game
Zach came up with an idea of you look
cute in that dress
thank you I like that I know you did
yeah I wish it was a little bit shorter
it's already released it needs to be
like up here no it doesn't yeah see my
booty ass hanging out hell yeah put some
[ __ ] booty shorts on that thanks
Zach said whenever he thinks of the 90s
all these things all he thinks of is
brown lipstick in the nanny when I think
of the 90s all I think of is grunge and
Vanilla Ice and everything being extreme
you know what I mean and like all those
shows that like had like smart ass
teenagers and kids like the [ __ ] kid
from Terminator two like that like sums
up the 90s for me
I don't know man it's just like
it was just something about the 90s I
just really didn't like I just really
didn't like it I didn't what I think it
was mostly I didn't like the way the
goth scene went I didn't like that it
went kind of like in a more
cybery Direction I didn't like I don't
know there was just like a lot of [ __ ] I
didn't like
I like some music from the early 90s but
once it got into like 95 96 I was like
yep
out of that
yeah I think he said
before it's like I wish that I played
more horror video games like because I
kind of some of them that I've seen like
look really cool and I kind of wish that
I had more time to like get into them
you know what I mean
there was a stand-up game we used like
it was called Splatterhouse
me and Steve and stud would play it
back in high school
I mean we're living up in Michigan
he would scroll by and you played Jason
going through now see that's the kind of
thing I could get yeah you basically
played Jason
and you scroll by you were going through
this [ __ ] haunted house
you had Xenomorphs coming up you were
killing them killing wait how many
franchises do we have going on here is
that like [ __ ] aliens yeah it had all
well they looked like Xena boys Michael
Michael Myers in there there's all kinds
of Freddy from all the [ __ ] horror
movies
just like yeah copyright protective but
it's like they had to look at us like no
they changed him up a little bit it's
Freddy Krueger right change them up a
little bit it was a Japanese game so
they could get around it by just making
it a little bit different you know but
you know what they were talking about
yeah Splatterhouse that was a good one
definite said I believe uh a case can be
made that the 90s was trying way too
hard to be cool that's exactly it thank
you you have just condensed down the
exact reason why I didn't like that it
was try hard it was too try hard I don't
know man everybody was yelling
everything was like had to be extreme
and loud and it's like and it's just I'm
like shut up
knock it off well no I just kind of felt
like that was like a whole like Vibe
they had some good [ __ ] that they did I
did I said that I said that there's good
[ __ ] some of the some of the good [ __ ]
bombed
but late it I thought it was really good
like for instance that the 90s is when
Billy Idol's cyberpunk album came out
and uh a lot of his fans didn't like it
uh the critics didn't like it
I love that album
went back and listened to listen to it
uh more recently and it was kind of
ahead of its time I mean it was
kind of like it was industrial it was
kind of like Nine Inch Nails a lot of it
uh with a lot of trance in it
and uh had decent videos for that album
and over time I think that that album
was proven to be correct
in what he did
they nearly [ __ ] [ __ ] it nearly
[ __ ] up his career
but that album can't it was a little bit
ahead of its time
you know so there was good [ __ ] that
came out in the night yeah I'm not
saying that even if it failed it was
pretty good because man that was pretty
good there was a lot of good children
that I bought a lot of music and I saw a
lot of movies in the 90s yeah garbage I
liked garbage yeah I like them too that
like attack was really good see there
you go
um there was there was a lot of good
[ __ ] and even like some old school like
[ __ ] [ __ ] from like the 80s put out
some good [ __ ] in the 90s but I do kind
of feel like like I said got the goth
scene since that was kind of more what
I've you know what I had the finger or
the pulse on I didn't like that it went
like more cyber and that it it went
cyber and then it also kind of went like
in that more dark wavy kind of like not
necessarily dark wave but that whole
like oh we're gonna do like this really
hard kind of background with like these
ethereal like female vocals and that got
old kind of fast Zach said uh I think my
all-time favorite 90s movie is Danny
Boyle's first movie Shallow Grave I
[ __ ] love that movie honestly I
didn't know
um I'm glad that you mentioned it
because I thought that a lot of people
hadn't seen that and it's so so good I
was thinking about it the other day
because I um I think I was scrolling
through HBO Max and you know they had
like some of Danny Boyle's other movies
obviously that were on there like his
more famous ones and I was like I wonder
why nobody talks about shallow grave I
used to have it on DVD but I don't know
if I have it anymore but maybe one of
these days I'll do
a review on it and uh yeah I totally
should because I really do like that
movie I really do like that movie
yeah Jeff yard said anything that was
created in the 90s then became so
commercialized to the point where it's
almost meh yeah I kind of feel like
that's what it was it was just kind of
like look okay like when Tim Burton's
Beetlejuice first came out for example
like in 1988 or whenever the [ __ ] that
was like um you know you saw the trailer
for that and you're like well yeah that
looks like weird as [ __ ] I'm into that
but then like as time went on it became
like a thing and then everybody got into
it you know like I look I love Nightmare
Before Christmas I do
but when after that came out in 1993 man
that [ __ ] was everywhere like the merch
for it was everywhere you know and so I
just kind of feel like everything got
you know it was a lot of things it was
Hot Topic it was the [ __ ] Underworld
franchise it was The Matrix it was all
that kind of stuff and I'm just like
you know I don't know I just didn't like
it I didn't like the commercialization
of
[ __ ] that I was really into like for all
this time that I'm like you're making it
suck knock it off you know what I mean I
don't know I just didn't like it and so
I I just think of that like every time I
think of the 90s now even though there
was good [ __ ] that came out in the 90s
there's lots of good [ __ ] that came in
the 90s but I didn't quite see it that
way
I saw you caught a commercialization I
kind of saw it as
The Goth scene starting to have enough
Fame and enough power to start breaking
through
and to like exert itself on on culture
yeah
yeah I was like yeah we are cool they
are copying us even like [ __ ] I mean
they've been doing that forever they
just like were like low-keyed yeah even
like television series like Millennium
came out they had a dude remember that
one had that dude that played uh Bishop
from [ __ ] alien oh yeah he was
playing kind of like a Paranormal
Investigator it was kind of like a I
mean I didn't see it but I remember
seeing it it was kind of like a it was
kind of like a uh
kind of like an X-Files spin-off a
little bit
and it had
kind of music
and a motif that was kind of like
etheric ethereal Gothic kind of a yeah
Motif to it so you could see that it was
breaking through you know it sounded
kind of like the the theme song and the
motive is kind of like some off of an
enigma album remember remember Enigma
yeah yeah we used to listen to that too
yeah and that's I like that but it's
just kind of like I think after a time I
was just kind of like I was kind of sick
of it being everywhere because it used
to be it was kind of cool because you
had to kind of like dig around for it
you know what I mean it wasn't like it
was just laying around everywhere I just
kind of feel like more it was too cool
to remain Underground
I guess and you had people in Hollywood
and in television from the scene and
they were putting it in there yeah
Burton would be the first one
[ __ ] got the [ __ ] well yeah all
those movies were goth
like I said when I saw the trailer for
Beetlejuice in the theater I don't
remember I it might have been who framed
Ryan was it here why do I want to say
that but I remember like going to the
movie theater and seeing the trailer for
Beetlejuice and at first I was kind of
like holy [ __ ] is that a real movie
that's awesome I had never seen like an
actual goth girl like Lydia like I
hadn't really seen that in a mainstream
movie before like I'd seen like
underground movies and stuff like that
that had Goth characters but you didn't
see it in a movie like that and I was
just like holy [ __ ] like I was I was
[ __ ] Blown Away
little did I know like a couple years
after that like everybody had to have a
[ __ ] goth character to movie after
that then I was like okay I'm sick of it
now you could stop but uh but yeah like
at the time that it happened like in
Beetlejuice I thought that was super
cool I'm like oh my God that's so
awesome for us it was the same thing
kind of like to see ourselves in these
movies
and in the mainstream was basically the
same thing Italian mafiosi would feel
when they would see them being in The
Godfather and in the movies like oh
we've been we're in the big time now
we're famous
we're famous we are important and that's
just kind of
how we felt when we saw that
and then blade came out remember blade
yeah I [ __ ] love blade man I thought
that was really good there was just a
lot of good goth movies you know the
crow
you know yeah Rebecca said about crows
yeah
which I didn't like when it came out but
I like it better now like now that I
have like some perspective on it because
it was such a long time ago because like
I said I think a lot of stuff that I saw
back then
um that was kind of like made for a goth
audience I was like I was mad at it it
was kind of watered down from our point
of view and it was kind of water now too
because like well the thing about it is
like when something like the crow came
out or Beetlejuice or something like
that like you know people that would go
see it that didn't know anything about
the god scene they'd be like woo look
how crazy this is and we'd be like yeah
that was like 10 years ago man we're
like where the [ __ ] have you been but
you know what I mean it was that kind of
thing so I think that's maybe why I was
mad at it which I know is a very hipster
thing but you know it was just kind of
like when
everybody got all like when all the mall
Goths or whatever you want to call them
like all got into Marilyn Manson and I'm
like
um you know skinny puppy would like a
word from like [ __ ] 15 years ago but
you know what I mean it's just kind of
like
you know and I get it I get not
everybody's into the same [ __ ] as me and
not everybody like knows about all this
like obscure [ __ ] and then when it hits
the mainstream suddenly everybody's into
it and I don't know it's just kind of
like pissed me off that you know I'd
been going to the castle for years and
years and then now suddenly you're going
and you're standing in line outside and
then like some dumbass like [ __ ]
chicks would come up and stand in line
and be like we love Marilyn Manson like
really loud like they thought they were
being really cool and everyone's just
looking at them like what the [ __ ] like
what the [ __ ] is your problem you know I
mean it's like nobody here likes
Maryland man it's it for the exact same
reason that I don't but I could I you
know I can appreciate Marilyn Manson now
but I still I'm not a huge fan but he
does like have some good songs I
actually kind of like his cover versions
more than his originals but
um you know at the time I was like God
damn it [ __ ] like why did you
why did you do that why did you do that
you [ __ ] it up and um yeah John Gore
said Interview with the Vampire was a
big breakthrough yeah and it's like I
shouldn't be mad because
I think in a lot of ways
yeah it's commercialization and stuff
but in a lot of ways like in Tim
Burton's case and stuff like that it
happened very organically because people
that you know of Our Generation that
grew up the same way that we grew up
liking the same [ __ ] that we liked
um you know they were creative people
and they got into you know some of them
got really successful in Creative Fields
so they kind of like brought their own
Vision to that and it just kind of
happened that it resonated with people
and that should be cool but I don't know
I couldn't help but be like a little bit
resentful about it I've gotten I've
gotten over it now because I'm old but
I still can't like think of the 90s
as anything other than because I was
like still pretty young then because I
was like I said that was that was the
decade after I graduated high school so
that that was the time that I was like
going to the most shows and that kind of
I went to some in the 80s too but
in the 90s I went to more because I had
more money and I had a car and [ __ ] like
that but
um Danny Rowling said the 90s Depeche
Mode albums violator and Ultra are good
yeah I actually really do like those uh
two albums I think Ultra though was the
last one that I bought
um I mean I like Depeche Mode I'm not
but I'm more into their 80s [ __ ] uh
their mid 80s [ __ ] specifically like
they're like from 82 to 80.
7-ish
88. when did um
what was that one Depeche Mode album
was it music what music for the masses
or whatever that one was that was good
but that's yeah so I mean I don't know
so even like bands that I liked
once the 90s came along
um
it seemed like their stuff started to
suck more and maybe that was just me
I don't know
like I said I was real into you know in
the 80s I was really into Bauhaus and
stuff so then I was into like Peter
Murphy's solo stuff loved his first one
it's a little and but you know it's
pretty good that came out in 86 and then
he did love hysteria which I which I
love that album Still that came out in
88 deep amazing that came out in 1990
and that was like his big I don't want
to say it was a breakthrough it didn't
go mainstream or anything but it was
like a pretty big seller like on the
college circuit and everything and he
toured and I saw him and everything now
after that he did
Cascade I think that came out in 95 no
he did holy smoke before that that was
92 which was pretty good Cascade was
actually really good that came out in 95
but then after that
he did this one album where he was very
clearly trying to be
he was he was very clearly trying to go
mainstream he got like the same producer
as like John Cougar Mellencamp it had
back in the day and some of the songs
were like really kind of like Poppy and
I was just like
I'm just not I'm like just lean into
like your thing dude you know what I
mean it's like I don't understand why he
couldn't be big and famous that's what I
mean it's like why can't you just be
happy with like what why can't why
couldn't he do like for like what Gary
Newman did like because Gary Newman you
know he had like that big hit back in
the 80s but he's like an industrial
music guy and he just leaned into that
[ __ ] and he's still huge like in the god
scene now like they play Gary Newman
songs like new ones like pretty much
every week at the bar and they're good
cool thing about Gary is that he's
totally open that it's a family business
shows his wife got his daughter up there
singing with him doing music videos with
his daughter he had a cute little
daughter yeah and uh
it's just I think it's kind of cool you
know I mean yeah he has her come up he
seems like a cool dude yeah yeah
but that's somebody that's his
daughter's name but everybody loves her
she was like a little little princess
probably about 10. when she he first
showed her off
I think she's about 19 18 now
yeah she's got to be she might be older
than that
yeah she's cute too she's cute well
wasn't that her and uh the my name is
ruin yeah yeah that's her right it's her
she's probably about 15 or 16 in there
yeah but I think she's 18 now yeah
because that was a few years ago if you
go on YouTube go my name is uh my name
is ruin
from uh uh
Gary Newman Gary Newman you'll see
you'll see what I'm talking about it's
just him and his daughter out of the
desert in post-apocalyptic golf clothes
[ __ ] man that's a big every time they
play a game at the goth bar everybody
dances we saw him live we have a good uh
Noob is great man my nose is totally
stuffed up yeah I was gonna say you
sound awful I took my mucus medicine and
everything whatever it takes before
but see that's the thing it's like I
kind of just wish like look if you're if
that's your thing then just lean into it
you know like don't try to be something
that you're not I kind of feel like
that's why I got mad
at Peter Murphy because he was clearly
trying to be
he wanted to be like a mainstream pop
star and I was like look at this point
it's too late you might as well because
you know he's older than I am
you know and it's like look everybody
loved you from like Bauhaus and like
your early like solo [ __ ] and everything
like that it's like just lean into that
you don't got to be like Oh I'm too cool
for goth or anything like that just you
know that's where your fan base is I
don't like understand why like I get you
know look I'm a creative person too it's
like I get that some artists are like
man I don't want to be like hemmed it or
boxed in I want to be able to do what I
want like that's cool too but you know
if you're into like darker [ __ ] do that
you'll find an audience like don't worry
about being like [ __ ]
some big pop stars like that because
most people aren't going to be that and
to be that you have to be kind of like
lame
you know you don't want to be somebody
that's just
liked by everybody because then you're
just like not watered down yeah you're
just kind of like watered down and like
not that interesting be interesting
you'll find it you'll find an audience
maybe or maybe it won't I don't know
life isn't fair
life isn't fair
Jeff yard said I remember Millennium it
actually was in X-Files uh spin-off
that's what I said fun fact when it was
canceled the storyline was concluded in
an episode of X-Files a New Year's
episode of all things with zombies and
you know actually X-Files was this was
not a spin-off but like kind of um
inspired by a 70s series called colchach
The Night Stalker did you ever see that
uh it was about a detective that went
around like some like werewolves and
vampires and stuff like that it's super
fun I said maybe I'll do that on my
scarce lawn Channel because I've been
wanting to re-watch all the Kolchak
shows I mean it might be a while but I
might get around to doing that
Rebecca said I love the ax file still do
it's the only TV series I actually
remember watching religiously you know
what's weird I never I never got into it
well I saw a couple episodes I'm like
man this seems like something I should
watch and then like I just never did I
think because it's more sci-fi and like
I said I'm more like I'm more of a
horror girl like I like the X-Files kind
of vibe but
um
oh okay oh see you later happy Halloween
okay I mean we'll be back on Halloween
night doing yeah talking about a
haunting and other things
but I don't know like I said I was kind
of more like into I'm more into like
straight horror stuff like I'll watch
some sci-fi but it's never like my main
priority type thing so I know a lot of
people do like the X-Files though I'll
get around to it one of these days but
[ __ ] man I haven't even like watched all
of American Horror Story
I think I watched some of the first
season and I'm like oh man this seems
pretty cool and now what it's like eight
[ __ ] nine ten seasons in and I'm like
well
I'm way behind now so
and there's still like a bunch of old
[ __ ] that I need to watch too I'm just
never gonna catch up never gonna catch
up
um they're saying about Gary uh Daniel
Rowling said Gary Newman collabing With
Fear Factory doing a metal version of
cars was a great idea yeah I think
actually I think the last time we were
mannequins they played that didn't they
yeah I think so I think I remember I
just thought he was cool because uh
he's an older guy
and uh proud of his family Eddie's you
know to be [ __ ] look I got a hot wife
look I got a cute daughter [ __ ] this
is the show and you guys are part of my
family and they're part of the show you
know I just thought that was really cool
the only guy he's the only guy that's
done that usually uh
uh an industrial or rock type artist
kind of they try to rebate aloof they
always try to make look like they're
single or something and he didn't do
that did the opposite that he's actually
kind of like a cool family man
yeah I always kind of like that like
Vibe about him well because he seems
like because he's on the Spectrum yeah
he's yeah
um so I kind of feel like he doesn't
really have any uh Illusions about it's
like oh I think I'm cooler than I
actually am or anything he's just like
he just likes that [ __ ] and that's what
he's doing he's got Asperger's yeah
but he knows it yeah yeah
plus he's go like he's you know he flies
planes and everything like that yeah he
said like I read this really long piece
about him like not too long ago and he
just like seems like a nice uh a nice
dude he's a smart guy yeah and so I just
like that I like that he's
just himself he's not trying to be
anything that he's he must be well off
because uh
he's constantly posting videos of the
same house over and over again I guess
it's his house is [ __ ] laid out is it
yeah it's beautiful house
I wonder where most of his money comes
from I mean I know that he sells like
um
ooh thank you very much Katie Perez cat
and Pat here drinks are ready all right
yeah we just I just filled one up I mean
this is my third one I think but we're
all right my sinuses are totally [ __ ]
stuffed up just out of the blue just go
oh man did you take some yeah I had the
[ __ ] and it got worse oh well maybe
maybe it'll get it maybe it'll get
better
maybe you canceled it out because you
took like both things at once I don't
know I'm just making sure I'm making
[ __ ] up
but I don't know I just
I kind of feel like especially nowadays
you know maybe back in the old days when
you know the media was very limited yeah
yeah you had to like water your [ __ ]
down to like appeal to as many people as
possible Katie and her boyfriend are
coming down are they yeah yeah they want
to get a hotel in this area over there
near Sanford probably okay take them out
to the club okay because they're gonna
be around for about a week
and I can't keep them here for a week
because because of our work schedule but
they can come over to the house and [ __ ]
yeah you come hang out every year that's
fine so it's a little golf couple it's
hammered at her boyfriend her
boyfriend's uh got the dreadlocks I
showed them to you before yeah yeah okay
yeah I know you're talking about yeah no
you guys come down when you can but you
got their contact they're keeping up
with me and uh direct messages but once
we all work it all out that we'll uh
we'll have yeah I'm coming to kids and
[ __ ] and then yeah you guys need to go
to Universal when you're here
okay yeah I think I feel like that
probably but uh try to find a good
uh like weekly rate at some of these
places here and if you if you get it
early you'll get a better price for it
but the I sent him two links
to like these travel hotels
that actually kind of like little
apartments
and you might be able for like maybe 300
bucks stay there for a week or something
well I don't know about 300 bucks 400
maybe 500 I don't know
I thought it was only like 300 a week
dude I stayed for five days in a Airbnb
in St Augustine like in just like a
bedroom and like a little fridge and
stuff and I think that was like 900
something dollars 900 was that much I
didn't realize it was that much
yeah and that was like for a little
bitty tiny like in a in a house like in
a big house like where there was a bunch
of others you spent that much yeah oh
[ __ ] yeah okay
I mean that was most of the money I
spent because most of the other [ __ ] I
did was like low cost but yeah I think
it was she spent 900 bucks to get away
from me for a week ain't that some [ __ ]
hey it was a vacation I hadn't had one
in a long time
she's got the bail escorts show it up
you wouldn't select any of the things
things that I did you don't like going
to museums or nothing like that or
alligator farm or all the stuff that I
did I had a good time though yeah no I
didn't that's what I mean I don't want
to listen to you like whining for five
days
about how you did it how it's like this
is so boring whatever he's like looking
you know what I mean so
I'm not being mean he thinks I'm going
there and like [ __ ] hiring male
escort I'm like dude seriously one dude
is enough of a pain in the ass okay
that's all I'm gonna say
one dude is enough a pain in the ass I
don't need an even bigger headache all
right so that's all that is
um let's see
Zach says uh living on the same street
as long as I did at my parents place it
was hilarious seeing how as The Years
passed the effort for holiday
decorations got less and less and less
but I mean you know
people still do like I was looking down
the street here the other day people
have all kind of like [ __ ] Halloween
decorations I was telling people like
yeah you make jokes about like me going
away for it and it wasn't a week it was
five days because I couldn't afford a
whole week all right but
um I don't know like what you think I'm
doing I'm like dude it's like dude
you're enough of a pain in the ass I
don't like need like other dudes on top
of that Jesus Christ I know she's took
it you're enough of it
you're enough of a headache
it's like why would I need more of that
Anthony says eat a fresh mango and see
if that opens your statuses up like I
got a [ __ ] fresh mango dude I mean
you might yeah
uh also maybe a cup of coffee
just keep blowing my nose it'll it'll
clear I mean you can make I got a little
coffee pot over there it just makes one
little cup at a time no I got I got
McDonald's coffee in the can that's what
I got this time
Rebecca said second X-Files movie is
[ __ ] awesome no aliens involved the
spin is not what you see that's I don't
know I kind of feel like I need to get
into it but there's a lot of things that
I need to get into that I'm really
behind on but
I don't know I feel like I don't I'm
just never gonna have time but in a way
that's kind of good because there's so
much cool [ __ ] out there that's like old
[ __ ] new [ __ ] everything like that and
like cool new [ __ ] is coming out all the
time too and I was like oh my God I'll
never catch up which in a way like
stresses me out but in a way I'm like
well maybe I shouldn't complain because
it'd be better than being like Oh man
there's like nothing to watch
because remember like back in the old
days when we only had like those are the
old old days when you only had like four
or five channels and then like later
when you had maybe 40 channels and even
then people were like complaining it's
like man there's not [ __ ] on you know
what I mean it was all corporate
[ __ ] anyway and advertising but
nowadays it's like holy crap I'll never
live long enough yeah to watch all the
cool all the cool [ __ ] that I want to
watch and it's like and it's not even
just like movies and shows and stuff but
it's books too like a lot of times I'll
scroll through like books and [ __ ] I'm
like oh man that sounds oh that sounds
good too it's like holy [ __ ] I'll never
have time to like read all these
I've been reading like one uh I'm doing
another Halloween Anthology even though
they're all um by the same author this
time because last week I did one that
was all different authors which was
called literally dead which was actually
excellent like all the stories and
they're really good this one is and it
is short stories but it's all the same
author and it's called This is Halloween
so I'm gonna put that up on Monday
um Jeffy art says fresh Wasabi or
horseradish does wonders for clogged
sinuses
Oscar says silver Shamrock yeah
sorry now that's stuck in everyone's
head no well because that's what I call
the show three more days till Halloween
Halloween
stop I could stop
oh
no just stop it stop it stop it stop it
stop it no there's a um
I think there's a shirt I saw a t-shirt
the other day like an ad for it that has
him on it
that she says stop it stop it stop it
and I was like uh I kind of want that
Rebecca said I have a seven foot fence
that is 360 Degrees around my property
and so it's pointless and decorating for
Halloween honestly we do the lazy
decorating for Halloween we just have
like the little projector
things we have that for Christmas too
like that's the latest because it looks
good and you don't have to do much
you know what I mean
we just have the one it's like we have a
little ghost one and a little bat one
like I think the bats are purple and the
ghosts are white we just have like the
two projectors like on the garage door
and on the regular door what's the
matter calling me now foreign
and then
um
for Christmas we have what's a Christmas
one do we have Santa faces and like
peppermint things or something I don't
remember what the Christmas ones are
because the next door neighbors here's
the thing I'm not like look I'm not
hating if you have some of those like
inflatable things like for Halloween or
for Christmas because I know people have
that too what
there's nothing in the closet seriously
open the closet yeah
every time I open the door she like runs
in there and she looks at me like what
the [ __ ] it's like they're why do you
think there's something in there
I don't get it but um
but yeah so like next door they have
like the inflatable things and during
the day like while they're at work
obviously they turn them off like they
don't have the inflatable [ __ ] on there
like the air so
you just look next door and there's like
a bunch of it just looks like a pile of
Rags like in the yard
it only looks good at night so I'm just
like I don't know I don't get that
boy she's calling me
open the door for well don't like the
show's really brushed now oh we can get
a pressure if you want yeah
come here
Rebecca said oh the 90s late night porn
phone sex phone sex commercials I
remember those yeah yeah I do too yeah
it was so cringe especially when you're
up watching TV with your dad yeah
awkward I never saw this one but
I saw it referenced on uh Mystery
Science Theater who are from Minnesota
by the way and they said that there was
one that was local to Minnesota that was
a phone sex line that was specifically
for water sports
and so it was called what was it 1 900
something
p-e or something like that so it had
something to do with p and but that was
like kind of a funny I can't remember
like what the actual like wording was
but so they thought it was so funny that
they kept like making references to it
like on the show like much later on I
never saw like a water sports one but uh
yeah I I don't know it's just funny
because before there was porn
on the internet
you've had to like I can't imagine
calling a 900 number
and like having somebody like talk to
you about whatever your fetish is and
then charge you a hundred dollars and
they charge you like a hundred dollars
yeah because they'd be like
what was it like the first three minutes
was like five dollars and then it's like
then in little over a minute a little
bitty type at the bottom they'd say oh
and by the way and yeah and that was the
whole thing is they were supposed to
like keep you on for as long as possible
and a lot of times that was like just
women that were like living in some
trailer somewhere and they were just
like working from home so
who knows what they look like or
anything and they're just like sitting
with fat girls babies [ __ ] crying in
the background all right anyways all my
Bacon's burning yeah you know what I
mean
ah 976 evil I gotta do that movie one of
these days too all right Jim we've been
on for a couple hours and uh I don't
know about you but it's I'm getting kind
of hungry I'll make us a pork tenderloin
okay how long is that gonna take
oh not long oh okay I'm just asking no
I'm just asking I'll slice it there to
cook it okay maybe I'll get a sandwich
yeah would you like it with the
vegetables on the side
I mean either way is good okay actually
even on a sandwich with vegetables on
the side is fine too like you could you
can even do both of those things why not
both why not both okay pork tenderloin
thought
Anthony said did you see Cleopatra in St
Augustine in the Lightner Museum
stunning I did not I did go to the
Lightner Museum though and that place is
amazing I'm gonna have to go back there
because I've been to St Augustine lots
of times but I never for whatever reason
I never went in the legendary Museum but
I went this time and man I just I was
like why did I never [ __ ] come to
this place before it's amazing
um Oracle said I have next week off from
work first vacation I've had all year
yeah I mean me going to St Augustine
that was
more than a year ago and that was the
first vacation I'd had in probably eight
or nine years so
Rebecca said had a cousin that rocked up
four thousand dollar phone bill in the
mid 90s calling porn phone lines he
didn't realize he was calling as an
Israeli phone number oh [ __ ] it was
probably an old lady on the other end of
the phone that's what I mean you don't
know it's just like a voice
holy [ __ ]
um
I can't imagine I mean read the fine
print people I mean that's the thing
like people don't call this [ __ ] anymore
do they have those anymore probably not
why would they have those no
um are you ready to are you ready to
like yeah I'm ready you sound like
you're having some problems I have a lot
of problems with sinuses okay
okay so tomorrow night we were probably
gonna go to a Halloween party so Sunday
we are gonna go yeah we'll probably do
it okay well I'm just saying yeah in
case I don't know something else might
happen but so oh that reminds me that
tonight we should probably watch
something to talk about on matinee on
Sunday so there's probably like a
Halloween movie yeah so it's awful late
it's not by the time to get done cooking
it'll be [ __ ] 9 30 probably
we'll pick something short okay I have
one in mind that's like from the 80s
it's maybe like cheesy all right so
hopefully you guys have a good day
tomorrow we will be back on Sunday
probably talking about a Halloween movie
and then Monday we're gonna do our
haunting show but also like a Halloween
special at the same time so it'll
probably be kind of like a Sidetrack
slash haunting kind of thing I'll
hopefully be in costume we'll see how it
goes because I gotta try the costume out
tomorrow night but uh yeah thanks for
hanging out with us this evening and
thanks for all your super chats and we
will see you guys again on Sunday
evening good night